Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir sind wütend, dass es einen Artikel in The Athletic und The Washington Post und viele andere gemacht hat. Und es ist meine Meinung, dass jeder Einer, ein Exekutiv, ein Juba-Soccer-Official, der die Spieler verfeuert und die Spieler verfeuert, die hinter Legalen geblieben sind, und nicht voll in diesen Investigationen teilgenommen hat, sollte weg sein.
Ja und wer mehr zu der Entwicklung so auch ein bisschen unter Persönlichkeiten, die so im US-amerikanischen Fußballverband so rumgelaufen sind, der kann sich nochmal unser langes Gespräch zum FIFA-Prozess angucken. Ich habe gerade das alte Sendungsdokument nochmal aufgemacht und nochmal geguckt, welche Namen da alles vorkommen. Es war ein Kabinett des Grauen, aber vielleicht lasst uns doch an der Stelle mal einen anderen Ton hören, den du auch mitgebracht hast, nämlich eben genau jene Vorgängerin Lisa Baird, die letzte Kommission der Liga, also Geschäftsführerin, würde ich jetzt übersetzen, der Liga. Was sie dann eigentlich gesagt hat zu einer der wesentlich an der Aufdeckung dieser Missbrauchsfälle beteiligten Reporterinnen, nämlich Lisa Salter. Also das ist aus der ESPN Doku Truth Be Told. Ihr habt es an der dramatischen Musik gehört und sie wurde eben gefragt oder sie hat angefangen mit ihrer Antwort. Ja, vergessen Sie nicht, dass ich erst im März 2020 bei der Liga angefangen habe. Die ganzen Anschuldigungen, die Behauptungen, die kamen, die lagen ja schon vor meiner Zeit zurück. Dann wird sie gefragt von der Reporterin, glauben Sie, dass Sie zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt Anschuldigungen gegen einen Trainer oder Trainerin ignoriert haben? Und dann sagt sie, nein, wenn etwas an mich herangetragen wurde, bin ich dem nachgegangen. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, Jürgen, auf Grundlage des aktuellen Berichts muss man das doch als Lüge bezeichnen.
Ja, ist schwer zu erklären, warum sie sich in diese Situation gebracht hat, weil die Doku belegt das eben mithilfe von Materialien. Also zwei Spielerinnen haben sich an sie gewandt, Sinead Ferelly und Manasim, mit unterschiedlichen Anliegen, aber es ging in beiden Fällen um Paul Riley, den Trainer, den wir schon mal erwähnt haben, der damals in Portland gearbeitet hat und der jetzt zuletzt in North Carolina, North Carolina Courage, im Einsatz war und dort dann auch hochkantig, achtkantig rausgeflogen ist, als das alles bekannt wurde vor einem Jahr. Die Frauen haben zumindest ein paar Dinge sehr geschickt und klug gemacht, also zum Beispiel sich mit E-Mails an Stellen gewandt, wie zum Beispiel dem Verband oder wie dieser Commissioner-Person Lisa Bärth. Und dann gibt es Antworten, die kommen dann zwar nicht gleich postwendend, aber nach ein paar Tagen oder ein paar Wochen. Und diese Antworten liegen schriftlich vor und die lassen sich auch von der Kamera legen und einscannen. Und die zeigen zum Beispiel in diesem Fall, dass diese Frau nicht die Wahrheit sagt. Also sie wird sicherlich sich überlegt haben, wie sie das so gut wie möglich abschwächt. Aber sie hat auch nicht das Talent wie ein Donald Trump, der sich daraus sofort zu einem Opfer stilisieren würde, wie man nur darauf kommen könnte oder so. Die Frau sitzt, also das habt ihr ja jetzt noch nicht gesehen, vielleicht könnt ihr das ja irgendwann mal über Stream angucken, die sitzt da jetzt auf der Couch in dieser Aufnahmesituation und wirkt aber so, als hätte man sie so ein bisschen dahingetragen. Die fühlt sich da nicht wohl und dann sagt sie aber etwas, was so nicht stimmt, weil sie hat das schriftlich diesen Spielerinnen gesagt, ich habe da was nachgecheckt, die Sachen sind final untersucht worden und da ist nichts nachgekommen oder so. Tatsächlich ist da nie was richtig untersucht worden und wir haben jetzt erst zum ersten Mal die Situation, dass es wirklich sehr gründlich untersucht worden ist. Das heißt, diese Frau, Lisa Bärth, steht für die Gruppe der Leute, die beschwichtigen, die abwiegeln, die vertuschen wollen und die keine Sorgen haben wollen, wenn solche Sachen auftauchen. Da hat sie dann gesagt, ich war ja eh nicht hier, als das passiert ist, also warum sollte ich mich jetzt darum kümmern? Und dieses Gefühl, das ist herbe, dass jemand, der in der Verantwortung steht, aber sich nicht verantwortlich fühlt und sich auch als nicht zuständig erklärt, das ist Teil des Problems.
Und es zeigt eben, warum der Bericht auch zu dem Ergebnis kommen musste, dass eben die Vorfälle von Missbrauch nicht adäquat adressiert wurden und es eben deshalb möglich war, dass Täter fröhlich von Team zu Team gewechselt sind. Und das ist tatsächlich einfach so, wie ich es jetzt formuliert habe, richtig? Die hatten einen Grund, relativ fröhlich zu sein. Da kommen wir, glaube ich, bei den Fallbeispielen auch noch mal genäher drauf. Und es rührt gleichzeitig noch an einen übergeordneten Punkt, der, glaube ich, wichtig zu erwähnen ist. Denn was dieser Untersuchungsbericht und im Grunde jetzt alles, was im letzten Jahr passiert ist, sehr deutlich noch mal herausstreicht, ist, dass Teil des Problems eine Kultur des Wegschauens und der Angst war. Und dieser erste Teil des Wegschauens, den haben wir vielleicht in Lisa Baird ganz gut aufgefangen, da ist sie natürlich nicht die Einzige, aber dass eben Beschwerden oft nicht weitergeleitet wurden oder konsequenzenlos blieben, das hat natürlich auch dazu geführt, da sagt auch der Bericht sehr deutlich, dass sich weniger Spielerinnen geäußert haben. Und im Fall der NWSL hat es noch die eine zusätzliche Wollte, dass die wirtschaftlich nicht-rosige Lage der Liga sogar noch ausgenutzt wurde, um Spielerinnen ruhig zu stellen. Du willst doch nicht dieser Liga, in der sowieso viele Teams Probleme damit haben, sich zu finanzieren, die eben nicht auf wirtschaftlich gesunden Beinen steht und die eben schon der dritte Versuch ist, den Frauenfußball als Liga zu etablieren in den USA. Du willst doch nicht dieser Liga schaden, indem du jetzt mit deinen Vorwürfen an die Öffentlichkeit trittst. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz perfides Spiel und gleichzeitig etwas, gegenüber dem man sich ja schon, wenn man sich das einfach nur imaginiert, machtlos vorkommt. Und dann will ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie das eben aus Sicht von Spielerinnen, die Betroffene waren oder sind, sich angefühlt haben muss.
Ja, mir fällt an dieser Stelle auf, es ist natürlich nicht nur das Problem in dem Fall oft ja auch sexualisierte Gewalt, sexualisierter Mist oder sexueller Missbrauch. Wir haben im Sport natürlich auch noch andere, durchaus ähnlich strukturierte Problemzonen, also zum Beispiel Rassismus im Sport, der dann zwar sich eine andere Gruppe aussucht, die man irgendwie fertig machen kann, die man runter machen kann oder so. Und manchmal sind es aber auch dunkelhäutige Frauen oder so. Also wir haben sicherlich auch noch andere Dinge nennen können, wo man auch erkennen kann, dass dieser in seinem Ursprung im Grunde autoritär strukturierter Betrieb Fußball, durchaus so ähnlich wie die katholische Kirche, die ja nun auch tatsächlich auf dem von oben nach unten regieren beruht, dass das eben nicht nur ein Aspekt, also es ist ein Aspekt, aber es ist nicht der einzige Aspekt, auch wenn wir heute jetzt uns sehr, sehr genau und sehr intensiv mit diesem Bereich beschäftigen. Ich würde bitten, dass sich alle, die sensibilisiert sind, auch die anderen Dinge angucken, die im Sport schieflaufen. Und wir haben in Deutschland jetzt zum Beispiel erst jetzt solche Entwicklungen wie Athleten Deutschland, wo sich also das wachsende Selbstbewusstsein der Sportlerinnen und Sportler dokumentiert und die auch bereit sind, selber sich zu engagieren, fast so wie eine Gewerkschaft oder wie eine Interessenorganisation. Weil sie gemerkt haben, die Funktionäre mögen unheimlich gut reden, aber sie tun nicht wirklich etwas für die Sportler und die müssen nicht selten zu Rechtsanwälten, Sportrechtsspezialisten wandern, um ihre Rechte wahrnehmen zu können. Und dann haben wir diesen, ich weiß auch nicht genau, was da alles an Vorwürfen aufgekommen ist, aber im DOSB, also dem Deutschen Olympischen Sportbund, die Führungsetage, wurde mit das sehr großen Anstrengungen ausgewechselt, weil auch dort konnte man erkennen, da wird von oben nach unten regiert und wer da einmal oben angekommen ist, dank der Seilschaftsprinzipien, die da gepflegt werden, der benutzt auch Mittel, die auf jeden Fall ethisch-moralisch nicht okay sind und vielleicht in manchen Fällen sogar auch hier justiziabel sind oder wenn man sich anguckt, was wir aus dem DFB immer wieder gehört haben, sodass da verschiedene Generationen von Präsidenten sich immer wieder mit merkwürdigen Verhaltensweisen vorgestellt haben und so, also ich will das nicht verwässern, ich will nur sagen, Augen auf!
Ja, der Schwimmverband der Deutschen ist da definitiv auch ein gutes Beispiel für. Tatsächlich ist das interessante Phänomen, das Strukturelle, was man erkennen kann, im Großen wie im Kleinen sind Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse und du hast es jetzt gerade im Großen beschrieben mit deinen letzten Beispielen, eben die OSB, die EFB und andere Verbände. Da haben wir es im Großen eben, dass sich Abhängigkeiten bilden und wir haben das aber eben auch im Kleinen und eben bis runter auf die Ebene Spielerin-Coach, also jetzt in diesem Fall Spielerin-Coach, kann natürlich auch Spieler-Coach sein, was eben auch ganz klar ein Teil des Problems ist. Zum einen die Kultur auch, die Normalisierung von Tough-Coaching, wird das jetzt hier im Bericht genannt, also dass eben eine gewisse Härte im Umgang miteinander schon im Jugendbereich normalisiert wurde und deswegen auch vielleicht manche Grenzübertretungen so gar nicht erkennbar waren und sowohl auch für die Opfer jetzt eben, also es soll jetzt kein Täterschutzargument sein, sondern auch für die Opfer war es nicht zu erkennen, dass das, was hier gerade passiert, schon eine Grenzüberschreitung darstellt und gleichzeitig, und das ist natürlich jetzt dann im Leistungssport, hat das nochmal eine besondere Bedeutung, stehen eben die Spielerinnen auch in einem krassen Abhängigkeitsverhältnis zu ihren Trainern. In dem Fall waren es zum Teil auch Trainer, die noch in der Funktion als Manager zusätzlich noch tätig waren, d.h. selbst ein Transfer konnte dann verhindert werden. Und dieses Ausnutzen von Abhängigkeiten, das ist ein zugrundelegendes Prinzip von ganz vielen Missbrauchsfällen und das haben wir eben hier auch bis auf die kleinste Ebene hier runter, bis hin zu dem Argument, was wir auch damals im Kurzpass schon mal kurz thematisiert hatten. Wir müssen uns die Fußballspielerinnen, die hier betroffen sind, die dürfen wir uns nicht vorstellen, wie Fußballer hierzulande, also männliche Fußballer hierzulande, die jetzt gar nicht wissen, wo sie ihren dritten Großwagen SUV noch parken sollen, sondern das sind Spielerinnen, die sogar unter dem dem durchschnittlichen Einkommen verdient haben. Also viele haben weniger als 31.000 Dollar im Jahr verdient, zum Teil in Wohnungen der Vereine gelebt, in dem zum Teil die Trainer manchmal auch eben wie die Manager gearbeitet haben und die ihnen diese Wohnung sogar auch verschafft haben. Also dieses Geflecht von Abhängigkeiten, das begünstigt eben auch Missbrauch und das ist zum Beispiel auch, wenn du sagst Augen auf bei den Verbänden, dann sage ich ja und Augen auf auch bei solchen Abhängigkeitsverhältnissen im Kleinen, wenn es keine kontrollierende und im Zweifel auch regulierende Instanz gibt. Es denn dann kann eben sowas sehr sehr leicht passieren, weil der eine ist vom anderen so abgehabhängig, dass man fast schon von dem ausgeliefert sein sprechen kann, denn hier möchte ja jemand seinem Traum nachgehen Leistungssport zu betreiben und dafür ist man ja sowieso schon bereit viel zu öffnen. Man muss letztlich viel körperliche Gesundheit unter anderem opfern und da ist das eben dann vielleicht ein besonders einfacher Weg, das dann noch weiter auszunutzen aus Täterperspektive. Diesen Aspekt wollte ich noch mit reinbringen. Das sind so im Groben die Ergebnisse dieses Untersuchungsberichts, zumindest die großen Linien. Ich wollte noch kurz ein paar Worte mit dir darüber verlieren, wie dieser Bericht erstellt wurde. Also es war ein rein weibliches Team, das Sally Yates zusammen mit der Anwaltskanzlei, mit der sie gearbeitet hat, zusammengestellt hat und dieses rein weibliche Team, das hat richtig, also das hat richtig Arbeit weggeschrubbt jetzt in diesem Jahr. Also die haben sehr, sehr viele Menschen zum nächsten Mal gesprochen.
Ja, ich glaube die Zahl, die jetzt genannt wurde, ist 200 Gespräche, die geführt wurden. Und die Zahl hätte noch höher sein können, aber es gab natürlich auch Leute, die sich da rausschmuggeln konnten, weil sie nicht wollten. Und was ich vorhin schon mal gesagt habe, so ein normaler Staatsanwalt in den USA, wenn er denn durch alle Teile des Verfahrens legitimiert ist, der kann natürlich Leute vorladen, der kann sie untereid befragen und kann also eine andere Art von Druck ausüben. Das kann jetzt jemand wie hier nicht. Ich dachte aber noch an noch was anderes. Vielleicht darf ich den Sprung noch einbauen. Wir hatten ja auch schon mal über die FIFA gesprochen und wie wenig ein Michael Garcia nach Hause gebracht hat im Vergleich, als es um ganz, ganz wichtige Sachen ging.
Der sogenannte Chef-Ermittler.
Ja, und ich glaube, man kann schon auch den leisen Verdacht formulieren, dass jemand wie Michael Garcia, der nun heute ein nicht wichtiger Richter irgendwo auf einer Bank auf irgendeinem Gericht in New York State ist, dass der eben kein richtig guter Ermittler war für das, was da anstand, dass da also auch erst durch die amerikanischen Strafverfolgungsbehörden richtig Licht reingekommen ist in die Geschichte. Während hier, das ist mein Eindruck, eine Frau wie Sally Yates, die ist halt ein anderes Kaliber. Die hat halt nicht einfach nur so ein bisschen rumgewedelt und ein bisschen Eindruck geschunden und so, sondern die hat wirklich ein paar Steine umgedreht und hat eben diesen sehr kompakten Bericht zusammengekriegt und der wird auch, glaube ich, das belegen wir hier auch, weil wir darüber reden und ein deutsches Publikum haben, der wird auch in anderen Teilen der Welt wahrgenommen. Also die Geschichte, die ich jetzt diese Woche zu dem Thema in der FAZ gemacht habe, die wurde da groß als Aufmacher des Tages platziert. Das heißt also die Bewertung dessen, was hier vorgelegt worden ist, die ist auch außerhalb der USA deutlich zu erkennen.
Ja, und genau deswegen wollte ich eben auch nochmal erklären, wie ist dieses Team vorgegangen. Also sie haben über 200 Interviews geführt, sie haben über 89.000 Dokumente und Dateien gesichtet, dazu noch öffentlich einsehbare Artikel, Filme, Social-Media-Posts. Es gibt einen weitreichenden Anhang im Anhang zu diesem Bericht, den ich natürlich, ich habe das noch gar nicht erwähnt, aber das habt ihr euch schon gedacht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass der auch verlinkt wird in den Show Notes. Das ist ja fast schon klar. Und was ich eben ganz fantastisch fand an diesem Bericht und was ich mir wünsche, auch für alle deutschen Berichte, die es gibt, sie haben auch sehr deutlich aufgeführt, wer sich alles nicht äußern wollte. Also da wäre Dan Flynn, der ehemalige Verbandschef. Rory Dames, das ist einer der Träne, über den wir gleich sprechen werden. Der hat sich nur über seinen Anwalt geäußert. Paul Reilly hat sich nicht mal schriftlich geäußert. Sie haben das auch in einer fast schon keckenart und weise beschrieben, was ihnen da versprochen wurde und was dann leider dann doch nicht geklappt hat. Also ich glaube, da auch eine gewisse Ironie fast manchmal ein bisschen herauszulesen. Jeff Plush, ein früherer Kommissioner, also Generalsekretär oder Geschäftsführer der Liga, hat nicht reagiert. BJ Snow, ein ehemaliger Trainer der Jugendteams der USA, hat nicht reagiert. Und, und da wird es natürlich besonders interessant, weil das betrifft jetzt dann auch jetzt handelnde Personen oder bis vor kurzem noch handelnde Personen. Es haben auch manche Vereine geblockt und ich glaube, das lohnt hier noch mal kurz inne zu halten und das zu resümieren. Wer sich da wie quer gestellt hat, Jürgen?
Ja, und da gibt es, das sehe ich hier gerade auf Seite drei, das Bericht. Da wird auch darauf hingewiesen, wie Leute dann argumentieren. Also das zum Beispiel, weil solche Fälle mit stillschweigenden Kündigungen endeten, wie im Fall von Christy Holley von Racing Louisville FC, der nur nach ein paar Monaten seinen Job da verlor, weil da einiges bekannt wurde. Da wurden aber von allen Beteiligten so Verschwiegenheitserklärungen unterschrieben, so nach dem Motto, okay, wir haben das jetzt hier auf folgende Weise gelöst. Wir wollen hier Herrn Holley nicht weiter rufschädigend verabschieden. Wir wollen das eher stillschweigend machen. Das Wichtigste ist, dass er nicht mehr bei uns ist und dass der Wunsch, den dann jemand hat wie Holley, ist sicherlich, okay, dann lass uns bitte hier mal einen Schwur treffen unter uns, dass wir also darüber nie wieder reden werden. Und natürlich kann sowas in einem, was heißt natürlich, ich müsste jetzt erklären. Wenn es ein strafrechtliches Verfahren gäbe, könnte ein Staatsanwalt zu einem Richter gehen und sagen, ich wüsste jetzt gerne mal genauer, was da passiert ist und könnte erreichen, dass all diese Verschwiegenheitsgelypte aufgehoben werden, nach dem Motto, die können nicht dazu benutzt werden, um strafrechtliche Vergehen zu vertuschen. Aber hier reden wir nicht von Strafrecht. Ich glaube, das ist im grauen Bereich, wahrscheinlich wird eben kein Staatsanwalt sich da einbringen. Und so kommen dann Leute damit durch, dass sie nicht sagen, ich will nichts sagen, sondern sie sagen, ich darf nichts sagen. Natürlich Teil des Systems. Also das System ist darauf abgestellt, alles irgendwie klein zu machen und klein zu reden und die Probleme auf den Sankt-Nimmerleins-Tag zu verlegen.
Und gleichzeitig diese Verschwiegenheitserklärung sogar auf ehemalige Mitarbeitende auszuweiten und ehemalige Spielerinnen. Also Racing Looseville hat sich da nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert, hat nur 41 Dokumente geliefert. Ich mochte auch, dass das so genau diese Zahl genannt wurde, weil vorher waren die Zeilen immer sehr große genannt worden. Also wir haben 89.000 Dokumente durchgeguckt und das und das und das und das gemacht und von denen haben wir übrigens 41 Dokumente geliefert bekommen und ich fand dann auch, das möchte ich kurz zitieren, die Formulierung interessant und da meine ich eben auch so ein bisschen einen Unterton zu erkennen. While Lewis Will essentially told us that, Zitat, quote unquote, their hands were tied by the non-disagreement and non-disclosure agreements, we learned through our interview of Christie Holley that Lewis Will never attempted to modify those agreements with Holley to facilitate cooperation with our investigation. Also während die uns gesagt haben, na, unsere Hände sind gebunden eben durch diese Verschwiegenheitserklärung, die wir da unterschrieben haben, hat uns der betroffene Trainer gesagt, ja, die haben ja gar nicht mit mir, haben wir nie drüber gesprochen, ob wir das vielleicht aufheben könnten für diesen Fall. Und das steht dann eben einfach so als einen Satz da drin und das finde ich großartig und das wünsche ich mir für andere Untersuchungen auch, weil es eben eine Bedeutung hat. Es ist wichtig zu wissen, wie haben sich die aktuell Verantwortlichen bei Racing Lewis Bill verhalten, wie haben sich zum Beispiel die bei Chicago Red Stars verhalten, die auch eine Kooperation mit den VfL Wolfsburg-Frauen zum Beispiel haben, die haben Dokumente erst mit Monaten Verspätung geliefert und dann erst nur solche, die einen Trainer betroffen haben, über den wir auch noch sprechen werden, Rory Dames. Aber ansonsten ist da nicht besonders viel gekommen und auch die Portland Thorns, über die wir im Kurzpass damals schon gesprochen haben, wo es mit Paul Riley alles losging, die haben Dokumente erst zurückgehalten, auch mit Hinweis auf das anwaltliche Schweigegebot, haben dann Monate Verzug erzeugt und sich nicht beteiligt. Die für Human Resources Verantwortlichen, also Human Resources, weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht, wie man das auf Deutsch am besten übersetzt, also es geht...
Das ist so die Personalabteilung, aber mit so einem euphemistischen Touch, ja, also das klingt so edel oder so. Das sind natürlich eigentlich auch nur die Interessenvertreter derer, die oben sitzen und die die Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen irgendwie in Check halten, aber immerhin sind das Leute, die sich eventuell für solche Sachen interessieren und wenn die offiziell was erfahren, auch nicht einfach sagen können, ne, interessiere mich nicht, sondern die sind dafür zuständig, dann eigene Ermittlungen oder so anzustellen. Also Human Resources ist ein typisch amerikanischer euphemistischer Ausdruck.
Ja, und das sagt ja schon alles, wenn Resources ein Euphemismus sein soll, das ist ja so, wie ich versuche das Wort Spielermaterial endlich aus meinem Vokabular herauszubekommen, weil ich das nicht möchte, Menschen als Material zu bezeichnen. Aber wer zum Beispiel die Office mal gesehen hat auf Netflix, da gibt es ja unter anderem einen Human Resources-Typ, beziehungsweise später kommt auch eine Frau dazu. Da sieht man eben auch, die haben genau mit solchen Fällen eben auch zu tun. Also wenn es zum Beispiel zu Sexual Harassment, also sexuelle Belästigung am Arbeitsplatz kommt oder zu ungebührlichem Verhalten, dann gibt es da eben auch gewisse Protokolle, die erfüllt werden, beziehungsweise wenn es diese Protokolle gibt, eins der Probleme, die es jetzt im vorliegenden Fall gibt, dann gibt es dann eben Schulungen, die durchgeführt werden müssen, die Beteiligten müssen sich äußern, das alles wird dokumentiert, kommt im Personalakten. Also da steht nochmal mehr dahinter und die dafür Verantwortliche, und die wäre ja höchst interessant als Gesprächspartnerin gewesen, die hatte schon ein Gespräch zugesagt und dann hat sie offenbar, nachdem sie nochmal Rücksprache gehalten hat mit ihren Chefs, hat sie dann doch zurückziehen müssen und hat sich eben nicht beteiligt an dieser Untersuchung. Und das fand ich eben sehr interessant, wie das in diesem Bericht offengelegt wurde. Und das hat ja auch, ich glaube da können wir schon vorgreifen, Jürgen, das hat ja auch zu Konsequenzen schon geführt, jetzt in der aktuellen Jetztzeit.
Ja, es kleckert nach. Also bei den Thorns ist das jetzt so, wie das Echo auf diese Dinge, dass sie untätig einfach nur Dinge schlucken und sagen, ja gut, ich habe das hier schön dokumentiert, aber mit uns hat das nichts zu tun. Also diese Argumentation, wir sind ja eigentlich raus aus der Nummer, weil wir haben ja diese ganzen Erklärungen und wir haben das ja abgearbeitet. Das funktioniert eben nicht und das wollte ich eben auch noch schnell einschieben, ich weiß ja, du wirst einen Link setzen in den Shownotes für Menschen, um dieses Papier zu finden, dieses Dokument im Netz. Bitte nicht verschreckt darauf reagieren, dass es so lang ist und so viel Englisch. Man kann sich zum Beispiel schon mit der sogenannten Executive Summary, also mit dem, was vorneweg schon mal zusammenfassend geschrieben wird, kommt man schon sehr gut mit dem Thema klar. Also der Rest ist dann mehr für die Spezialisten, die sagen, okay, ich will das hier ganz genau wissen. Also bitte nicht erschrecken, wenn ihr das dann vor euch habt. Das ist halt ein wunderbar detailliertes Inhaltsverzeichnis und so. Also es ist ein sehr brauchbares Dokument, das wollte ich noch sagen. Ich bin ja da gewohnt, mit solchen Dingen zu arbeiten und freue mich, dass sowas auch in Amerika total üblich ist. Dass das dann offiziell öffentlich gemacht wird und dass man sich dann auch als Journalist vertieft damit beschäftigen kann und nicht hinter allem Kram hinterherjagen muss. Also das ist nur jetzt mal meine Ermunterung an alle, die uns jetzt bis hier hin zugehört haben und immer noch ganz neugierig sind. Es lohnt sich. Schaut rein.
Ja, es ist auch so geschrieben, dass man das sehr leicht versteht. Vielleicht können wir an der Stelle sogar noch mal kurz Becky Sauerbrunn zu Wort kommen lassen, mit Teilen davon, die habt ihr dann schon im Intro gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn Becky Sauerbrunn ist eben eine Spielerin von Portland Thorns und hat eben, also ihr müsst euch das vorstellen, ihr seid auf Länderspielreise. Jetzt gerade in England sind die Frauen des US-amerikanischen Fußballteams. Und dann kommt eben dieser Bericht raus und da spielt euer Verein eine Rolle und eine unrühmliche Rolle. Und ich glaube, all das fließt in ein Statement, das sie getan hat, getätigt hat, in der ersten Pressekonferenz nacherscheinen dieses Berichts. Wir haben es in Teilen im Intro schon mal gehört, ich musste es allerdings ein bisschen zusammenschneiden. Und deswegen würde ich es gerne an dieser Stelle nochmal in voller Länge abspielen, weil ich finde, die Perspektive der Spielerinnen darf hier auf gar keinen Fall untergehen, denn das ist die aller, aller Wichtigste.
Wir sind wütend, dass es einen Artikel in The Athletic und The Washington Post und viele andere mit über 200 Menschen, die ihre Trauma teilen, um zu diesem Punkt zu kommen.
Also ich fasse es noch mal kurz zusammen. Sie hat gesagt, die Spielerinnen, es geht ihnen nicht gut. Sie sind hartbrocken, also am Boden zerstört und sie sind wütend. Sie sind wütend, weil es eben eine Untersuchung einer dritten Partei gebraucht hat, um das alles aufzudecken. Sie sind wütend, weil es erst durch Artikel losgestoßen wurde. Die Washington Post, die Athletic, wir hatten es im Kurzpass und auch hier in diesem Tribünengespräch kurz thematisiert. Sie sind wütend, weil es eben 200 Menschen gebraucht hat, die ihre traumatische Erfahrung nochmal hervorkramen mussten. Sie nennt nochmal alle Betroffenen, die auch mit ihren Namen an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen sind. Sie sind wütend, weil diese Spielerinnen nicht ernst genommen wurden von den Entscheidern. Und das ist eben jetzt dann der Punkt, der auch schon zu Konsequenzen geführt hat nach diesem Bericht. Weil eben diese Entscheider sich dazu entschlossen haben, nichts zu tun. Und eben sie sagt, you have failed, ihr habt darin versagt, uns zu beschützen. Und sie kommt dann eben zu dem Fazit, was wir vorhin im Intro schon gehört haben. Jeder, der daran beteiligt war und der sich dafür entschieden hat, sie alle müssen weg. They all have to be gone. Und das ist ja in Teilen auch schon passiert, Jürgen.
Ja, und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der öffentliche Druck die wichtigste Rolle spielt hierbei. Also dass dieses Salopp gesagt, dass dieser Bericht über Bande gespielt wird. Und dass er also erstmal an einem oder zwei Tagen in der vollen Wirkung so in die Öffentlichkeit gerät. Und dass man also auch die Informationen konsumieren und verdauen kann. Und eventuell auch diese Dokumentarfilm-Geschichte von ESPN sehen kann, die das noch mal auf eine andere Art und Weise dokumentiert und verstärkt. Und dann kommen halt diese, was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, über Bande gespielt. Dann kommen halt diese Echo-Dimensionen. Und dass Becky jetzt sich äußert, ist ein Beispiel dafür. Auf dem Motto, das können wir jetzt auch nicht einfach so liegen lassen und darüber hinweggehen. Nach dem Motto, ja, ich habe jetzt jeder seine Arbeit geleistet, dankeschön. Sally, geh wieder bitte in dein Büro und mach was anderes. Sondern, ja, wir brauchen, wir müssen handeln und die Spielerinnen sind nicht in der Lage, das zu tun. Sie können nur dokumentieren, wie betroffen sie sind und was sie eventuell tun würden. Ich denke mal, es ist immer in solchen Entwicklungen ein gewisses Tau ziehen. Also da gucken sich Leute gegenseitig an und sagen, okay, gehst du jetzt zuerst? Gehe ich jetzt zuerst? Wie sieht das aus? Was macht das für ein Eindruck? Haben wir neue, die einspringen können, die das hier weiterführen können oder so? Es ist ja oft ja auch eine Frage, gefährdet man nicht wirklich diese Verwaltungsabläufe und die Management-Sachen in solchen Organismen? Man kann nicht einfach nur mit dem Hackeball da durchwandern unter der Machete. Aber die haben sich jetzt Gedanken gemacht und es wird sein, dass es auch Eigentümer gibt, die angefangen haben, sich selbstkritisch zu hinterfragen. Und das ist nun nicht so neu. Das gibt es in amerikanischen Mannschaftssportarten wie Basketball auch. Also auch dort ist, wenn der Druck vor allen Dingen über die Aktiven hochkommt und die Schlagzeilen bestimmt, der Druck auf die, die wieder etwas mitbewegen können, die sagen können, ne, sagen wir mal jetzt der Verband oder so, der hat sich noch gar nicht geäußert darüber, wie er mit Personalfragen in dieser Sache umgeht. Die haben sich also erstmal nur mit einem sehr allgemeinen Statement geäußert, dass sie, also ich habe das hier in der FAZ so kurz zusammengefasst, dass sie also als erste Sofortmaßnahme angekündigt haben, ein Büro zu eröffnen, das die Sicherheit der Spielerinnen und die Verhaltensrichtlinien überwacht. Außerdem soll eine zentrale Datenbank errichtet werden, in der Personen aufgeführt werden, gegen die Disziplinarverfahren, Suspendierungen oder Sperren ausgesprochen werden oder worden sind. Das ist natürlich wichtig und das wird sicherlich auch passieren. Das wird für die Zukunft eine Rolle spielen. Aber Yeats hat auch an einer anderen Stelle in dem von uns schon eingespielten Interview gesagt, dass man sich auch wirklich mit den Existierenden oder den alten Sachen gründlich beschäftigen muss. Man muss aufarbeiten. Es geht nicht einfach an, dass man sagt, ja Schwamm drüber, das war halt doof, aber jetzt machen wir alles besser. Da müssen Konsequenzen getroffen werden, die dokumentieren, dass da eine Art von Lernprozess stattgefunden hat.
Und das hat eben zu personellen Konsequenzen in Teilen schon geführt. Also bei den Portland Thorns hat sich zum Beispiel der Franchise-Eigentümer Merit Paulson schon angekündigt, sich zurückzuziehen. Am Tag darauf wurde dann klar, dass auch der Sportdirektor Gavin Wilkinson und der Geschäftsführer Mike Golub jetzt entlassen wurden. Es gibt auch schon bei den Chicago Red Stars, ist der Owner Arnim Wissler vom Aufsichtsrat entfernt worden, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Weiter habe ich jetzt aber noch nicht erkennen können, ob er sich auch von diesem Franchise dann trennt. Also das sind eben die personellen Wechsel, die es jetzt dann gibt, die Konsequenzen aus diesem Bericht. Und diesen Aspekt wollte ich eben an dieser Stelle kurz auffangen. Ich würde jetzt gerne dann überleiten, dass wir mal noch detaillierter in diesen Report reingucken. Und vielleicht, weil das auch irritierend sein könnte, also auch die Triggerwarnung zum Beispiel, die ich vor einiger Zeit ja schon ausgesprochen habe. Warum braucht es die eigentlich? Das hängt damit zusammen, wie dieser Report erstellt. Und auch das hat Sally Yates noch mal erklärt, wie es eigentlich dazu kommt, dass sie sehr detailliert auch Begebenheiten rekonstruieren, die wir dann jetzt eben auch gleich mal uns angucken werden. Natürlich hinter einer schützenden Kapitelmarke. Aber wir hören noch mal kurz rein, wie sie das beschrieben hat, denn das fand ich interessant. Sie sagt, als wir das untersucht haben und gesehen haben, wie verbreitet die Fälle vom Missbrauch waren, dachten wir, dass es wirklich wichtig wäre, dies als eine Geschichte zu erzählen. Wir hielten es für sehr wichtig, dass man sich die einzelnen Frauen, die in diesem Fall gelitten haben, aus der Nähe ansieht. Denn der Missbrauch, den sie in ihrem Bericht aufzeigen, hat System. Und das fand ich bemerkenswert und finde ich auch an diesem Untersuchungsbericht bemerkenswert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das vielleicht auch ein anderer kultureller Umgang ist in solchen Berichten. Das kannst du sicherlich besser einordnen, Jürgen. Aber er ist eben dann tatsächlich sehr detailliert.
Also ich glaube schon, dass alle Beteiligten, die die vertuschen und davonlaufen, Sorge haben, dass juristische Konsequenzen entstehen können, wenn sie Fehler machen. So ist das auch hier. Nur, Yates ist halt eine erfahrene Juristin. Das heißt, sie weiß ganz genau, sie kann nur bestimmte Sachen auch aufbringen hier. Also die können nicht so dokumentiert sein, dass jemand der mutmaßlichen Täter sagen kann, ich bin hier also zu Unrecht in ein falsches Licht gerückt worden und ich gehe jetzt dagegen vor. Und da gibt es nun eben einfach eine Methode, wie man dem entkommen kann. Also statt irgendwelche groben Einschätzungen und Meinungen zu vorbereiten, die wären vielleicht gedeckt von dem amerikanischen Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung, aber sie helfen natürlich nichts. Dann geht man halt eher in die andere Richtung. Man geht halt wirklich zu dem dokumentierbaren Detail und das heißt, das, was in dem Bericht gesagt wird, basiert eben auf Erklärungen von Interviewten. Das heißt, deren Aussagen sind die Grundlage für all das und wenn jetzt jemand dagegen argumentieren würde oder dagegen vorgehen würde, kann Frau Yates sagen, nee, Moment mal, ja. Und je detaillierter ich Dinge miteinander zusammenbringen kann, desto klarer kann ich auch ein System oder eine Methode oder einen Serientatbestand dokumentieren und das ist in diesem Fall natürlich auch wichtig. Also Leute wie Paul Riley werden nicht dafür angegangen, dass sie mal irgendwann irgendeiner Frau unter die Bluse gefasst haben. Also einmal oder so, das ist hier gar nicht das Thema. Das Thema ist, hier nutzt einer seine Position aus und das macht er egal, wo er arbeitet, weil er nicht mahnt und gebremst wird. Und das kann man nur über Details dokumentieren. Also das wäre jetzt sicherlich auch mein Anspruch an jeden anderen Bericht aus, meinetwegen, deutscher Provenienz, wenn es um solche Sachverhalte geht. Man sollte das so tun. Ich glaube allerdings, dass wir Amerikaner, du hast ja den Kulturaspekt genannt, also es ist so ein bisschen wie auch mit der, was ich vorhin schon mal gesagt habe, mit diesem Gefühl, dass man in Amerika möglichst alle Regeln und alle Grundsätze und alles muss man irgendwie auf Papier bringen und aussprechen und nicht jetzt so einen Kodex aufstellen mit 15 Regeln oder so und dann machen die Schiedsrichter das, was sie da brauchen oder so. Und das ist auch hier so. Also wenn ich eine konkrete, ja wir würden hier vielleicht sagen, so eine Art Landkarte für zukünftige Fälle und zukünftige auch Ermittlungen geben kann, dann kann ich das besser, wenn ich im Detail arbeite und genau belege, was da passiert ist. Und wir haben ja hier auch jede Menge Fußnoten und so. In diesem Bericht wird ja nicht nur einfach was erzählt. Also das ist, sie hat zwar gesagt, sie erzählt eine Story in dem Bericht. Das hat damit zu tun, wie sie sprachlich mit dem ganzen Stoff umgeht. Aber nichts von dem, was da drin steht, kommt einfach von irgendwo. Die Sachen sind alle dokumentierbar. Und wenn jemand jetzt mit dem Anwalt käme und sagt, okay, wir gehen mal zurück zu dem, was wir hier liegen haben. Und ja, das ist, glaube ich, der Hauptgrund.
Also weit über 1000 Fußnoten, über 100 Seiten Anhäng, in dem man eben dann auch die SMS und anderen Nachrichten, die E-Mails nachlesen kann. Du hast das vorhin auch schon mal kurz thematisiert. Also das ist eben nicht Geschichte im Sinne von etwas Erfundenes, sondern als Geschichte erzählt. Dann lass mal hineingehen und eben die drei Fallbeispiele, die ja auch im Bericht vorkommen, nochmal nacherzählen. Es wird auch im Bericht gesagt, dass es durchaus noch weitere Täter gab, zu denen man dann aber aus unterschiedlichen Gründen, ich vermute, das hat dann auch mit Rechtlichen wahrscheinlich zu tun, sie eben nicht so herausgepuckt hat, gepickt hat. Du hast jetzt schon Paul Reilly häufiger erwähnt. Er ist einer der erfolgreichsten Trainer der NWSL, war, glaube ich, zweimal Trainer des Jahres. Er ist Besitzer eines Jugendclubs und Leiter einer Fußballschule für Kinder und Jugendliche. Und jetzt würde ich eigentlich die Zügel ein bisschen dir in die Hand geben, Jürgen, dass du uns durchführen kannst. Wir haben ein paar Soundbites auch dazu, die du uns besorgt hast und eben viel, was in diesem Bericht steht. Wie hat sich der Missbrauch im Fall von Paul Reilly abgespielt?
Also in diesem Fall haben wir keinen Ton, aber wir haben, ich habe das übersetzt aus dem Original Bericht, aus dem Report. Und zwar Paul Reilly, wir springen jetzt einfach mal rein, ohne ihn groß zu erklären. Also er ist eben ein erfolgreicher Trainer, speziell im Frauenfußball und hat da seine Meriten, wobei ich nicht ganz sicher bin, also ich habe nichts darüber gefunden, dass er vielleicht irgendwie ein taktischer Fuchs ist oder so. Möglicherweise hat er irgendeinen, mehr so eine Art, wie man ambitionierte Fußballerinnen in eine Mannschaft hineinschweißt und so einen Chorgeist.
Er hatte Erfolg, also so wie ich es gelesen habe, war es so, er kam über so eine Internship, das ist nicht so untypisch für das US-Sportsystem, also ein unbezahltes Praktikum, kam er zu einem Verein und hat dann irgendwann da Funktionen übernommen und seine Teams waren einfach erfolgreich und auch sein Jugendclub hatte wohl Erfolg. Das war so das, was ich nachrecherchiert hatte. Dadurch umwehte ihn so eine gewisse Aura des Erfolgs, die eben ein Teil der Erklärung dafür ist, warum so viele Menschen dann auch schon sehr früh in seiner Karriere weggeguckt haben.
Paul Reilly kann man natürlich auch googeln. Man muss jetzt nicht so viel mehr über ihn sagen, nur dass er eben wirklich eine Hausnummer war in der Liga und ernst genommen wurde als Trainer, der von Clubs auch sehr gerne erst mal angestellt worden ist. Also was im Sally Yates-Bericht auf Seite 53 über ihn gesagt wird, habe ich hier übersetzt. Da geht es um Sinead Farrelly, eine Frau übrigens, die er nach Portland geholt hat als Spielerin, als er dort den Laden übernahm und mit der er schon vorher in einem anderen Kontext auch intim zusammen gewesen war. Also eine damals den anderen Beteiligten völlig unklare Situation, weil beide haben darüber keine Details in Portland verbreitet. Sinead war sie. Im Laufe von zwei Jahren bei vier verschiedenen Gelegenheiten Sex mit ihr hatte, das erste Mal 2011 als Farrelly 21 und Riley 46 Jahre alt war, während sie bei Philadelphia Independence trainierte. Farrelly gab an, dass es sich beim letzten Mal, als Riley Sex mit ihr hatte, um einen Dreier mit einer anderen Spielerin handelte, in der Zeit bevor Sinead von Riley zu den Portland Thorns geholt wurde. Und an einer anderen Stelle, Seite 62 heißt es, Spielerinnen und Mitarbeiter der Portland Thorns und von Carolina Courage sagten, dass die Art und Weise, wie Riley über das Gewicht dieser Spielerinnen sprach, Essstörungen förderte. Eine Courage-Spielerin erinnerte sich, dass sie in der zweiten Saison unter Riley dünner war, als in der letzten, was auf eine Crashdeade und tägliches Laufen in der Vorsaison zurückzuführen war. Und sie wird da wörtlich zitiert, ein wahnsinniges Kaloriendefizit hatte sie sich dabei eingehandelt. Und diese Dame erinnerte sich, dass Riley zufrieden war. Er sagte, du siehst gut aus. Letztes Jahr sahst du aus, als wärst du von einem Bus überfahren worden. Als sie anschließend wieder zunahm, bestrafte er sie, indem er sie zwang, sich zu wiegen und ihm ihr Gewicht zwei Monate lang jeden Tag per SMS mitzuteilen. Er sagte ihr, dass sie erst wieder spielen könne, wenn sie das von ihm festgelegte Zielgewicht erreicht habe.
Also wir sehen, wie allein schon er ins Privatleben der Spielerin eingreift. Dazu haben wir auch von Mack Linehan, der The Athletic Reporterin, ein Zitat. Das kommt auch aus der ESPN-Doku. Das würde ich hier an dieser Stelle mal kurz einspielen. Also was sie eben von vielen Spielern gehört hat, also ich sage es jetzt so, wie es hieß, gesagt hat, was ich gehört habe, dass es keine wirkliche Barriere zwischen Trainer und Spielerin gibt. Er wollte Informationen über ihr Gewicht, über ihr Privatleben, ihre Beziehungen. Die Art und Weise, wie er das als Trainer betrachtete, war, dass er das Recht habe, alles zu wissen. Er hat die Macht und kann mit einem einzigen Telefonanruf meine Zukunft und die eine oder andere in die eine oder andere Richtung lenken. Das ist eben genau dieses Machtgefälle, was wir vorhin schonmal thematisiert haben. Und das muss er offenbar ganz gezielt ausgenutzt haben.
Und wir haben ein anderes Beispiel, ebenfalls aus der Doku, wo Mana Shim erzählt, wie er dabei vorgeht. Also sie hat nicht alles erzählt, aber sie hat das gut zusammengefasst. Und vielleicht können wir das schon gleich hängen.
He opened the door.
He was standing behind the door and he said, come in. He quickly shut the door behind me. And he told me to get on his bed and watch film. And at that moment I was just planning my exit. And that was the turning point for me, when I decided I was gonna, I was gonna say no to him.
Mana left Riley's room.
Also ich übersetze es noch kurz für euch oder nutze deine Übersetzung. Zuerst erzählt die Reporterin Lisa Salter, sie sagt, also mana shim, Riley habe sie zum Abendessen eingeladen, ihr explizite Fotos von sich geschickt und sie eingeladen, sich WM-Spiele anzusehen in ein Hotel, indem sie sich in ein Zimmer und ein Bett teilen würden. Dann im Juni 2015, während einer Reise nach Portland, sagt Monica, dass Riley sie gebeten hat, sich mit ihm für eine Filmanalyse zu treffen, spät am Abend in seinem Hotelzimmer. Also vermutlich ist damit ein Film von Spielen gemeint, also ein Video-Coaching, eine Coaching-Analysen. Er öffnete die Tür und das erzählt dann die Spielerin. Er öffnete die Tür und sagte, komm rein. Er schloss schnell die Tür hinter mir und ich sah, dass er nur Unterwäsche anhatte. Er sagte mir, ich solle mich auf sein Bett legen und Spielszenen im Fernsehen anschauen, aber es gab kein Video. In diesem Moment habe ich mir überlegt, wie ich hier wieder herauskomme. Ich hatte schreckliche Angst, aber ich wusste, ich muss einen Ausweg finden. Dass ich nicht bereit war, für meine Karriere oder für diese Person alles aufs Spiel zu setzen, das war ein Wendepunkt für mich.
Eine Anmerkung, ich habe etwas nicht korrekt übersetzt. Die englische Formulierung war Portland Away Game. Das wäre also ein Auswärtsspiel von Portland. Und ich habe das dann aber in meiner Übersetzung gar nicht gemerkt, dass ich da dachte, die sind nicht nach Portland gefahren, sondern sind von Portland zu einem Auswärtsspiel gefahren. Nur, das ist eine klitzekleine Kleinigkeit, aber das habe ich jetzt beim Zuhören gemerkt.
Ja, das ist aber eben sehr frappierend zu sehen, wie vermeintlich einfach das dann in diesen Fällen war. Also das soll jetzt bloß kein Victim-Blaming sein, aber wie leicht, glaube ich, Paul Reilly seine Machtsituation ausnutzen konnte. Und in diesem Fall bei Menachem hat es dann nicht funktioniert, weil sie die Kraft hatte, die mentale und auch physiologische in dieser Situation anders zu reagieren, aber wie schwer das allein für sie gemäß sein muss. Und was bei Paul Reilly eben das ist, was diesem Fall diese Bedeutung gibt, ich glaube auch in den USA, ist eben nicht nur die Bedeutung, die er hatte als Coach, sondern eben auch wie lange das alles ging. Also von 2015 bis 2021 gab es jedes Jahr Hinweise darauf an die Liga und den Verband, dass er eben sich Fehlverhalten geleistet hat. Und wir haben ja jetzt gerade gehört, es geht nicht nur um sexuellen Missbrauch oder sexuelle Gewalt gegen Frauen, sondern auch über mentale Gewalt, über diesen Kontrollfetischismus, dieses Hineindrängen in einen ungesunden Lebensstil. Also ich glaube, ihr versteht, was ich meine, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und ich möchte es nochmal wiederholen, von 2015 bis 2021 gab es jedes Jahr Hinweise darauf an Liga und Verband. Und wann hat sich etwas getan? Erst nach dem Bericht in The Athletic, was wir eben im letzten Oktober 2021 thematisiert haben, Jürgen, erst dann wurde dieser Mann gestoppt. Zumindest, was seine Profifußball-Trainer-Karriere angeht.
Ja und auch, weil Manasim selbst nach dieser langen Zeit, die da vergangen war, noch immer nicht aufgegeben hatte, etwas zu unternehmen. Aus einem Paralleluniversum, also in Kanada, gibt es viel Theater in verschiedenen Sportarten und es sind nicht nur Frauen betroffen, die Kanada erlebt gerade so eine Art Urimplosion, was die Kultur des Sportmanagements von Verbänden und Clubs angeht. Aber auch da kann man eben erkennen, es gibt ähnliche Mechanismen. Es gibt aber auch die Frauen, die wirklich nicht aufgeben. Die sagen, ich laufe hier nicht einfach weg und mache einen Deckel drauf. Es gibt diese wenigen Frauen, die sagen, das muss endlich mal wirklich rausgebracht werden. Das haben wir auch im Turnskandal in den USA erlebt. Das zog sich ja auch ewig hin. Und es gab zum Glück wenigstens ein paar Figuren, in denen die Parallele interessant war, die Frau, die als Athlete A in der Netflix-Doku gefeaturet wird, Dan Hollander, ist ihr Nachname, ist Anwältin geworden und hatte also einen bestimmten Sinn für die Rechtssystematik hier. Und Manas Him hat auch Jura studiert, irgendwann, nachdem sie mit dem Profifußball aufgehört hat. Ich habe keine Information, habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt, ob sie auch einen Abschluss gemacht hat und ob sie heute als Rechtsanwältin arbeitet. Aber immerhin, man kann erkennen, die Energie, die da entfaltet werden muss, die muss auch gegründet oder fundiert sein. Jemand, der eigentlich nur mit dem Problem persönlich fertig werden möchte, indem er sagt, na ich lasse das jetzt hier einfach mal, pack das jetzt hier weg und gebe auf, der kommt auch nicht an den Punkt, an dem wir heute gemeinsam sind.
Portland hat sich dann von ihm getrennt, aber ohne Angabe von Gründen, das ist ein sich durchziehendes Problem, was in diesem Bericht immer wieder auftaucht. Die Vereine, die dann informiert wurden und sich dann auch deshalb dann endlich auch zu einer Aktion durchgerungen haben, nämlich einen Trainer zu entlassen, die haben dann Presse-Statements mit rausgegeben, in dem dann von Mutual Agreement, also gegenseitigem Einvernehmen, gesprochen wurde, indem man den Coaches viel Erfolg für ihre Zukunft gewünscht hat. Also es wurde nicht nur die Öffentlichkeit nicht informiert, sondern auch ein falsches Bild gezeichnet und das hat sich ja im Fall von Paul Riley dann sogar durchgezogen. Er ist dann 2016 zu Western New York Flash gewechselt. Die wurden nicht über die internen Berichte informiert, die Portland schon diesen Zeitpunkt schon hatte. Und bei einem späteren Vereinswechsel war es sogar so, als sich der Verein dann erkundigt hatte, dann wurde gesagt, ja, also wir würden ihn uns holen. Das ist ein super Trainer. Und das ist halt das, was einen fast schon sprachlos macht, aber auch gleichzeitig die Dicke der Mauer zeigt, gegen die diese Frauen eben anrennen mussten, um irgendwie etwas verändern zu können in diesem System, das ja eben anscheinend darauf angelegt war, jahrelang Täter zu schützen und Dinge zu verschweigen.
Und die drei Figuren, die Sally Yates jetzt rausgearbeitet hat, also Paul Riley haben wir jetzt schon mal ein bisschen besser vorgestellt, aber dazu gibt es eben Rory Dames in Chicago und es gibt den Christy Holley in Louisville, die bringen andere Facetten mit rein. Also Holley ist der wirklich, der Grabscher, der Übergriffige, der also die Frauen dazu bringt, in einer privaten Situation sich quasi ausgeliefert zu fühlen und hilflos darauf zu reagieren, wie der sie anpackt, richtig, mit Händen. Und Rory Dames ist der, der diese Verbal-Injurien-Nummer pflegt, der aber auch dabei natürlich mit sexuellen oder mit, sagen wir mal, frauen-sensitiven Begriffen arbeitet. Also der hat ein ganzes Kaleidoskop von Begriffen drauf. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die jetzt alle hier bringen müssen.
Nee, bitte nicht.
Ich kann sagen, Seite 90, wer wirklich den Bericht sich anschauen möchte, da wird das im Detail besprochen. Und ich würde lieber bei Dames die Passage auf Seite 107 zitieren, in der seine Arbeit bei den Chicago Red Stars in der NWSL etwas allgemeiner eingestuft wird. Spieler berichteten davon, dass Dames eine Angstkultur schuf. Sie befürchteten, dass eine Meldung über seine Missbrauchshandlungen ihre Karriere beenden oder ihre Chancen in die Nationalmannschaft berufen zu werden, ruinieren würde. Die Befragten sagten auch, dass wenn Spieler die Fehlverhalten meldeten oder an Untersuchungen teilnahmen, oft entweder Vergeltungsmaßnahmen erlitten oder ihnen mit Skepsis oder Schweigen begegnet wurde. Also das wird hier auch alles mit hochgeholt und auf den Tisch geblättert und ist eben Teil dessen, was wir am Anfang schon mal darüber gesprochen haben. Es ist ein ganzes Panorama an Missbrauch.
Rory Dames war von 2013 bis 2021 Trainer bei Chicago Red Stars. Vorher war er ein erfolgreicher Nachwuchstrainer. Und hier haben wir eine ganze Reihe von Menschen. Also bei Paul Reilly ist es auch so, das wird ja alles wirklich minutiös nochmal aufgearbeitet. Und da kommt auch die vorhin gehörte Baird nicht ganz so gut weg. Aber bei Rory Dames gab es eine ganze Reihe von Menschen, die informiert wurden über seine Entgleisung. Gulati, den du vorhin schon angesprochen hattest, auch Flynn, Levin, Bailey. Also das sind alles dann wichtige Personen beim Verband und bei der Liga der Inhaber Arnim Wissler, von dem ich jetzt schon erzählt habe, dass er zumindest aus dem Board, also dem Aussichtsrat des Vereines jetzt schon mal entfernt wurde, die alle wurden informiert. Passiert ist über acht Jahre hinweg sehr, sehr wenig. Im Jahr 2018 hat sich sogar eine Nationalspielerin formell beim Verband beschwert, was immerhin eine Untersuchung eingeleitet hat. Lydia Walker, die oberste Justiziarin beim Verband, hat dann den Untersuchungsbericht aber nicht weitergeleitet, und als im Jahr 2021 der Verein eine weitere Untersuchung mit Unterstützung eines Psychologen eingeleitet hat, kam der zu einem Ergebnis, das macht einen fassungslos, das ist aber gleichzeitig so logisch und so wichtig zu wissen, dass ich es hier zitieren möchte, also Zitat aus dem Untersuchungsbericht. The Psychologist observed that 70% of the players interviewed, including most starting players, reported emotionally abusive behaviors, and that many players failed to recognize certain behaviors as abusive because they were so ubiquitous in women's soccer. Also nochmal kurz die schnelle Übersetzung, der eingeschaltete Psychologe hat beobachtet, dass 70% der interviewten Spielerinnen, von denen viele Stammspielerinnen waren, eben genau diesen emotionalen Misshandlungen durch eben Worte und Verhalten und eine Angstkultur beobachtet haben, aber dass die meisten von ihnen das gar nicht als solches misshandelnde Verhalten erkannt haben, weil es eben so allgegenwärtig im Frauenfußball ist. Aber das ist ja genau der Punkt, den wir vorhin auch schon mal gemacht haben und der aber nochmal wirklich wichtig, sich zu vergegenwärtigen, ist, eben, also zum einen, dass eben Abuse, also Misshandlung oder ich glaube, wir würden sagen, verbale Gewalt im Deutschen ist wahrscheinlich das bessere Wort, das kann eben auch durch Begrifflichkeiten stattfinden. Gleichzeitig kann man auch dadurch Grenzüberschreitungen vorbereiten. Also er hat eben nicht nur seine Spielerinnen wirklich aufs Schlimmste beschimpft. Das sind die Worte, die wir jetzt hier nicht zitieren wollen und davon wussten alle, das haben alle gehört. Das war nicht im Geheimen, sondern das war auf dem Trainingsplatz. Sondern er hat mit ihnen eben auch über sexuelle Vorlieben gesprochen, über ihr Sexleben, über... Also er ist da sehr ins Detail gegangen und hat eben dadurch auch Grenzen verschoben. Und das eine geht mit dem anderen, glaube ich, dann auch oft hand in Hand zumindest, dass es dann schwierig ist für die Beteiligte, diese Grenzüberschreitungen als solche noch wahrzunehmen. In einem Umfeld, das war ja das, was ich eingangs gesagt hatte, in dem es ja sowieso schon allgegenwärtig ist, dass ein rauerer Umgangston herrscht. Und gleichzeitig ist eben jemand wie Rory Dames das beste Beispiel dafür, warum man es eben nicht akzeptieren darf, dass auch nur irgendjemand mit der Argumentation kommt, ja, aber wenn man das nicht mehr sagen darf oder das muss man doch aushalten können. Dann lassen wir uns noch über das dritte Fallbeispiel sprechen, nämlich Christy Holley. Du hast ihn vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt. Der hat im Skyblue Football Club sich vom Praktikanten zum Headcoach hochgearbeitet, ist im Jahr 2016 dort Trainer geworden, musste dann allerdings sehr früh gehen, also im Sinne von nach ein paar Monaten schon als Headcoach, also als Trainer, weil er verbal ausfallend geworden sein soll und eine Beziehung zu einer Spielerin gehabt haben soll. Nach außen hieß es, das ist dann wieder das Muster, was ich vorhin schon mal hervorgehoben habe, man habe sich im gegenseitigen Einverständnis mitten in der Saison getrennt. Er hat dann beim Verband gearbeitet als Scout und in U17 und U23-Teams und er wurde dann im August 2020 Trainer bei Wrestling Louisville. Und du hast ihn vorhin schon mal den Grabscher genannt. Ich glaube, an der Stelle müssen wir dann auch nochmal ein kurzes Zitat aus dem Bericht vorlesen.
Das ist Seite 12. Also der wird als einer der ersten präsentiert hier. Holly hat auch eine Spielerin, so steht da, Aaron Simon, sexuell genötigt. Holly schickte ihr sexuell eindeutige Fotos und Nachrichten und verlangte von ihr, dass sie dasselbe tut. Er forderte sie auf, sich mit ihm in seinem Haus zu treffen, um Videoaufzeichnungen von Spielen anzuschauen, zeigte ihr aber stattdessen Pornos und masturbierte vor ihr bei einem Weitem.
Und das ist so ein Punkt. Also ich glaube, das ist, das ist tatsächlich eine der Passagen dieses Berichts, die ich nicht mehr vergessen werde. Denn ein Video-Studium zu nutzen, um eine Schauspielerin zu sehen, die sie in der Bildschirme hat, die sich in der Bildschirme auch in der Bildschirme auch in der Bildschirme für jeden Fehlpass noch weiter zu demütigen, indem man sie, indem man das zum Anlass nimmt, sie zu begrabschen. Und die Spielerin sagt auch, sie hat versucht, ihre Beine eng übereinander zu schlagen. Sie hat versucht, das aber so lachend wegzulachen, letztlich weil sie Angst hatte, weil sie schon in diesem Moment nicht wusste, wie komme ich aus dieser Situation heraus. Und es wurde dann auch beschrieben, sie wurde dann abgeholt von einer anderen Spielerin und hat eine andere Spielerin getroffen. Und nach diesem Vorfall ist direkt in Tränen ausgebrochen. Also es kann hier quasi nichts von Konsent, also Einverständnis zu sehen sein, null Komma null. Und gleichzeitig ist das so eine widerliche Verquickung von sportlicher Macht, jemand, der einen Fehler auf einem Platz gemacht hat, eben mit sexueller Belästigung, das ist, ja, also das war so eins dieser Beispiele, das wird mich, glaube ich, noch verfolgen und deswegen steht es wahrscheinlich in diesem Bericht drin, um eben auch die Widerlichkeit klar zu machen, die diese Fälle zum Teil haben.
Und auch dieses Fehlen an angemessenen Reaktionen darauf, wenn solche Dinge intern dann auch gemeldet werden, was ja in dem Fall auch passiert ist. Und man hat halt, ja, den Mann dann rausgeschmissen, aber man hat eben so getan, als könnte man das alles schwammdrüber irgendwie vergessen machen. Und das ist nun ein Fall im Unterschied zu dem, was die Riley-Situation in Portland angeht, der ist relativ frisch. Also das ist aus dem letzten Jahr. Da ist dieser Club in Louisville erst auf die Beine gestellt worden. Und da wenige Wochen nachdem die Saison begann, wurde das bereits aktenkundig.
Also wir sparen jetzt viele Details auch aus, aber ich glaube, es gibt einen Einblick, was in diesem Untersuchungsbericht aufgezeigt wird. Wollen wir vielleicht einmal zu den Empfehlungen des Reports kommen? Denn ein paar kann man sich, glaube ich, schon herleiten. Ein paar haben wir auch schon ein bisschen mit einfließen lassen. Aber ich glaube, das ist nochmal der Teil, der auch richtig interessant wird, auch mit Blick auf andere Länder, wie eben zum Beispiel Deutschland. Welche strukturellen Veränderungen empfiehlt denn jetzt eigentlich Sally Yates? Meine Güte, jetzt mache ich es wirklich jedes Mal falsch in diesem Bericht. Und das erste davon, das scheint eine Selbstverständlichkeit zu sein, ist es aber nicht. Und auch dafür haben wir diese Fallbeispiele gebraucht. Teams müssen verpflichtend Missbrauch an Liga und Verband melden. Und dazu soll auch eine Datenbank aufgebaut werden, in Zusammenarbeit mit den dafür Zuständigen beider Liga, beim Verband. Es scheint so naheliegend zu sein. Und dennoch ist das vielleicht eines der Grundübel gewesen, Jürgen, dass diese Kultur des Verschweigens auch dadurch gefördert wurde, dass es keinen Prozess dafür gab, was eigentlich getan werden muss im Fall der Fälle.
Ja, das ist die Schwachstelle, die inzwischen hinreichend dokumentiert ist. Also, wenn man die Information nicht zentralisiert, wenn man nicht versucht, eine Form von Klugheit über die Problemlage zusammenzugeben, sondern wenn man das einfach nur alles isoliert betrachtet und jeden einzelnen Fall als Einzelfall irgendwo wegheftet, dann kommt eben auch nicht das zustande, was dieser Yates-Bericht jetzt leistet, dass er eben wirklich den Zusammenhang herstellt, dass Trainer werden einfach, so wie die Priester in der katholischen Kirche, einfach weitergereicht, sobald da irgendwas hochkommt und so. Also, das kann man nur bekämpfen, wenn man, und sei es erstmal nur verbannsintern, es muss ja nicht unbedingt immer in der Öffentlichkeit abgehandelt werden, aber wenn man das transparent genug abhandelt und dazu gehören eben solche Informations-Clearing-Houses, also so Stellen, wo das alles zusammenkommt, so dass man auch sobald was auftaucht, kann man als erstes, das ist so ein bisschen wie beim FBI mit ihren Fingerabdrücken, also wenn man irgendwo Fingerabdrücke nimmt an einem Tatort, dann kann man als erstes da in den Computer gehen und gucken, kennen wir diesen Menschen schon. Und das kann man eben ja auch theoretisch hinbekommen, weil so viele Figuren gibt es da ja gar nicht. Also die Zahl der Trainer und die Zahl der potenziellen, übergriffigen Menschen ist ja nicht so groß. Und das muss man nur anfangen und dann fortführen und zwar gewissenhaft.
Und interessanterweise erwähnt der Bericht an dieser Stelle auch die Trainerlizenzen oder die Vergabe von Trainerlizenzen als ein mögliches, probates juristisches Mittel, um Trainer mit Missbrauchsvorfällen aus dem System zu bekommen. Also aktuell ist das noch so aufgebaut, dass man das wie ein Diplom einmal erwirbt, diese Lizenz und dann ist die für immer gültig. Der Untersuchungsbericht empfiehlt, so ähnlich ist es ein bisschen auch bei den Trainerlizenzen beim DFB, dass man immer mal wieder diese Lizenzen wieder auffrischen muss, dass es zudem Backgroundchecks von Trainern geben soll, die eine Lizenz erwerben wollen, dass sich der Verband auch um die Lizenzen der Liga kümmern soll und dass eben dann Täter, die Trainerlizenz entzogen werden kann, auch allen Komplizen, die untätig geblieben sind und nur solche Trainer mit einer Trainerlizenz durften in der Liga trainieren. Das wäre eben dann ein praktisches Mittel, um auch eine rechtliche Handhabe zu haben, denn das dürfen wir ja auch nicht vergessen, wir bewegen hier uns ja in einem Bereich, der auch juristisch abgesichert sein muss. Das fand ich aber in interessanten Gedanken, auch weil ich ehrlicherweise an der Stelle noch mal ein bisschen was über das Trainerlizenzsystem in den USA gelernt habe, das dann doch ein bisschen anders ist als hier in Deutschland.
Und in der Executive Summary, wo also vorneweg schon auch das Stichwort Empfehlung kurz abgehandelt wird, kommt diese allgemeine Gedanke zur Sprache. These recommendations are not exhaustive. Das heißt also, diese Empfehlungen sind noch nicht unbedingt alles, was man dazu machen könnte, sondern sie sind einfach nur gemacht worden, um einen Rahmen, einen gedanklichen und strukturellen Rahmen herzustellen, um vor allen Dingen die institutionellen Probleme bei solchen Fällen anzugehen. Wir reden ja jetzt noch nicht davon, wie kann man übergriffige Menschen vielleicht auch behandeln, im Sinne von psychologisch oder ärztlich oder medizinisch behandeln und dafür sorgen, dass die als Individuen vielleicht aufhören, sich so zu verhalten. Sondern es geht erstmal nur um die Strukturen und die Mechanismen, so wie sie sind und den Versuch, dass zumindest die, was hier in der Empfehlung heißt, provide a safe and respectful environment for professional women's soccer players. Das wird also jetzt hier auch nur ganz eng gefasst. Es geht um die Profi-Spielerinnen, die Profi-Fußballerinnen. Man versucht hier mit diesem Bericht nicht die ganze Welt, nicht die ganze Sportwelt zu beeinflussen oder so. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass alle Sportinteressierten sich mit den Gedanken, die hier aufgeworfen werden, auch beschäftigen sollten und auch können. Weil so viel anders ist es ja in den anderen Sportarten nicht. Oder das ist fast zu flapsig gesagt, es ist ja nicht anders in den anderen Sportarten.
Ja, ich denke der Untersuchungsbericht, der formuliert seine Empfehlungen aus dem Aspekt des Opferschutzes heraus völlig richtigerweise, wenn man seine Entstehung anguckt. Und weil das auch erstmal das Wichtigere ist. Und es gibt aber darüber hinausgehend sicherlich noch viele, viele weitere Felder, die man angehen müsste. Und gleichzeitig konzentriert sich der Bericht auch darauf, eben strukturell zu überlegen, was kann man verändern in den Strukturen zwischen den Vereinen, zwischen dem Verband und der Liga, dass eben Missbrauchsfälle erstmal, dass da ein Prozess in Gang getreten wird, ein verlässlicher Prozess. Und da empfehlen sie eben unter anderem, dass es eben verpflichtende zeitnah und gründliche Untersuchungen gibt bei entsprechenden Beschuldigungen. Dafür soll es Leitfäden geben. Die Teams dürfen die Vorfälle nicht bei sich selbst untersuchen. Ist vermeintlich trivial, aber dann doch ja eines der großen Probleme gewesen. Gleichzeitig soll es eine Verpflichtung geben, für Besitzer, Mitarbeitende und Spielerinnen an den Untersuchungen teilzunehmen. Sowie auch, dass es bezieht sich auf fast alle Empfehlungen, die der Bericht gibt. Es braucht natürlich auch Sanktionsmaßnahmen im Fall, dass da eben Beteiligte nicht mitmachen möchten. Also man braucht auch Druckmittel. Und das fand ich aber dann doch sehr interessant, Jürgen, wie strukturell, relativ klar die Empfehlungen auch formuliert sind. Das ist fast fast eine To-Do-Liste. Also das klingt jetzt, ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen flapsig, weil das sind große Veränderungen. Aber im Grunde gibt es da jetzt wirklich, also insgesamt sind es zwölf Empfehlungen, die ausgesprochen werden. Und da könnte man in einem Jahr hingehen und sagen, okay, jetzt machen wir mal Haken dran, was davon wurde umgesetzt. Es ist dann doch sehr auf die Praxis hingedacht, finde ich.
Ja, und auch der Verband, der ja nun der Auftraggeber für diesen Report war und ist, wird auch noch mal konkret angesprochen. Also wenn es um die Verflechtungen geht, zwischen Verband und der Liga, die ja hauptsächlich ökonomischer Natur sind, dass dort auch darauf geachtet wird, um diese Gemengel-Lage, die so viele Druckverhältnisse schaffen kann, also die Abhängigkeiten, das was wir hier Conflict of Interest nennen, also Interessenkonflikte. Das Wort ist eigentlich irreführend. Ein Interessenkonflikt ist ja nur dann einer, wenn man begreift, dass es sich um einen handelt. Vorher ist es auch schon einer, aber da habe ich jetzt kein richtiges Wort dafür. Also dass man nicht reinschlittert in diese gegenseitigen Abhängigkeits- und Seilschaftsdenkmechanismen. Also auch das soll hier mit angeschoben werden. Ich glaube, das ist zwar eine sehr abstrakte, ein abstrakter Punkt. Du hast schon sehr konkrete genannt, aber ein abstrakter Punkt. Aber ich glaube, dass man ein offenes Ohr jetzt hat, auch beim Verband, und sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt so viel Geld ausgegeben, um diese Ergebnisse zu bekommen. Und jetzt müssen wir auch vom Verband aus anfangen, uns genau damit zu beschäftigen, weil wir haben ja Druckmittel. Wir sind ja Mitsponsor dieser Liga. Der Verband braucht auch diese Liga. Damit ein Unterbau existiert für die Nationalmannschaft und für das, was die Jugendspielerinnen irgendwie anstreben. Aber sie ist erst mal durch die Konstruktion, das ist ja ganz anders als in anderen Mannschaftssportarten in den USA. Also Basketball, NBA und der amerikanische Basketballverband, das sind zwei völlig unterschiedliche Welten. Manchmal kommen die zusammen, aber das ist so mehr Gentleman's Agreement, wir haben jetzt eine Olympischen Spiele und wir haben Weltmeisterschaften. Könnt ihr uns ein paar Spieler geben oder so, weil wir würden gerne eine Goldmedaille holen. Und es ist ja auch gut, wenn diese Spieler sich dann gut zeigen können und so. Aber da gibt es nicht diese Enge, diesen Zusammenhang. Oder im Football gibt es gar keine nationalen Mannschaft. Wahrscheinlich ist es am deutlichsten, jetzt springen wir nach Kanada, die Eishockeylandschaft dort ist ähnlich furchtbar. Also das ist so ein Selbstbedienungsladen der Sonderklasse. Und die Kanadier versuchen gerade damit umzugehen und möglicherweise gucken die jetzt auch über die Grenze und gucken sich das mal hier an, auch um zu verstehen, wie man methodensicher arbeiten kann, um Dinge aufzuklären.
Ja und gleichzeitig ist ein interessanter Nebenaspekt, der Untersuchungsbericht sagt gleich zu seinem Anfang, also wir haben auch unsere Empfehlungen hinsichtlich der Kosten, die dafür aufkommen, formuliert. Also ich glaube, man will da gleich dieses Argument schon das Wasser abgraben, dass das gesagt wird, das sind alles ganz tolle Ideen, aber wir können das nicht umsetzen. Und gleichzeitig wird es aber später dann hier in den Empfehlungen dann auch nochmal aufgegriffen, wenn eben zum Beispiel empfohlen wird, in jedem Verband und im Team soll es eine für die Sicherheit oder Unversehrtheit der Spielerinnen zuständige Person geben, also ein Player Safety Officer, wird das dann genannt, die auch vierteljährlich Bericht erstatten sollen, entsprechende Mitarbeiter in den Vereinen sollen dort dann die Anlaufstelle bei Beschwerden sein, unter anderem sollen aber auch für Coachings zuständig sein, es soll ein Verhaltenskodex entwickelt werden, das öffentlich einsehbar ist und eben dann auch Informationsveranstaltungen geben, die auch klar machen, wo sind Grenzüberschreitungen, welche roten Linien müssen für alle klar definiert sein und Spielerinnen sollen auch über ihre Rechte und Möglichkeiten einer Beschwerde aufgeklärt werden. All das sollen diese Player Safety Officer in den Vereinen dann unternehmen, sollen Berichten an die Liga, sollen auch an den Verband berichten. Es muss dann auch Strukturen geben, sagt eben dieser Bericht, dass dann auch innerhalb des Verbandes das vorgestellt wird und es muss auch im Lichte einer gewissen Öffentlichkeit passieren. Also da geht es jetzt natürlich nicht so sehr ins Detail, aber das finde ich nochmal einen ganz interessanten Punkt. Wir sprechen jetzt hier immer so über die Schnittmenge an interner Kommunikation und externer Kommunikation und nicht alles, was intern ist, soll auch extern sein und gleichzeitig brauchen wir aber natürlich, und das haben wir an diesen Fällen auch gesehen, wir brauchen den Druck und das wachsame Auge der Öffentlichkeit, um zu verhindern, dass man da vielleicht zurückfällt in alte Muster oder nicht tatsächlich die neuen Muster überhaupt etabliert, die jetzt dringend geboten werden.
Mich hat noch beeindruckt eine Idee, die ist hier unter Punkt 8 abgehandelt. Die klingt, sobald man sie liest, klingt die völlig gut. Da muss man aber auch erstmal drauf kommen. Der Verband soll die Liga dazu zwingen, ein System oder ein Verfahren einzuführen, das einmal im Jahr die Spielerinnen dazu bittet, ihre Meinungen zu den Verhältnissen zu äußern. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das auch anonymisiert sein würde. Aber die Hauptidee ist, wir warten nicht, bis sich Spielerinnen beklagen und etwas vorbringen müssen und dann vielleicht nicht wissen, wie sie das am besten machen. Wir loten schon mal die Wassertemperatur, indem wir jedes Jahr checken, gibt es da Dinge, ist da irgendwas am Rumoren und müssen wir dann nicht vielleicht dem nachgehen. Also die Umkehr des Prinzips, dass man den Frauen die Pflicht auferlegt, zu sagen, naja, ihr wisst ja eigentlich, ist ja alles in Ordnung, aber wenn dann mal selten irgendwas passiert, dann müsst ihr eben bitte euch melden und was sagen, wenn man das auch ausbaut aus dem System. Das finde ich eine ganz faszinierende Leistung. Keine Ahnung, ob das so kommen wird, aber das ist eben auch ein Vorschlag hier.
Ja, ich halte das für gar nicht so unrealistisch, denn das war auch ein Detail, was mir aufgefallen ist im Untersuchungsbericht. Das scheint es in Teilen schon zu geben. Also eben als Beispiel bei Rory Dames war das der Fall. Da gab es eben zum Beispiel 2014 und 2015 Umfragen unter den Spielerinnen, die von der Liga und der Verbandsspitze wohl durchgeführt wurden und wo eben genau dieses, das unprofessionelle und misshandelnde Verhalten von ihm beschrieben wurde, zum Teil mit sehr drastischen Worten. Also es wird zitiert aus diesen anonymen Umfragen und man stellt sich die Frage, warum konnte da nichts passieren? Also es scheint schon eine gewisse Kultur dieses Feedbacks zu geben. Also Feedback ist mir jetzt fast ein bisschen zu beschönigend, aber es kann ja auch in jegliche Richtung gehen. Aber das muss wahrscheinlich nochmal institutionalisiert werden. Und was ich interessant finde, ist, dass auch alle Empfehlungen auf eine Repetition, eine Wiederholung setzen. Also auch darauf setzen, jetzt nicht einmal etwas zu machen und es dann liegen zu lassen, sondern es muss etabliert werden als ein wiederkehrender Prozess, damit sich da eben gar nicht erst die Möglichkeit einspielt, etwas eben nicht zu machen, vielleicht etwas zu vergessen oder aus Kostengründen einzusparen, sondern es zu verpflichten und so aufzusetzen, dass es auch für alle eine Verlässlichkeit hat, denn das ist ja einer der ganz wichtigen Punkte. Verlässlichkeit, die hat eben jetzt über Jahre hinweg gefehlt und ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem bei allen Dingen, über die wir jetzt hier schon gesprochen haben.
Ja, also das, was wir, glaube ich, unter Konsistenz auf Deutsch, ja, so ist es richtig. Ja, weil es gibt da wirklich ein Problem mit den deutschen und englischen Begriffen, also Consistency und Konsistenz, ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher. Also Konsistenz ist eigentlich die Textur von Dingen auf Deutsch und Consistency ist so die Konstante und Konsequente und alles, was gleich zu behandeln ist, auch gleich zu behandeln, also auf die gleiche Art und Weise zu behandeln. Also ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ich müsste das erst mal wieder nachschlagen, aber ich bin ja jetzt hier in dem Bericht tief drin. Wir müssen das irgendwie überspringen, glaube ich.
Der Untersuchungsbericht sagt auch, dass die Anforderung hinsichtlich Spielerinnen und Versehrtheit auch finanziell gesichert werden muss, also die Bedingungen an die Clubbesitzer müssen entsprechend verändert werden. Es soll jährliche Berichte über die Kultur bei den Teams und den Trainerausbildungen dargestellt werden. Es muss wieder Standards geben, die erfüllt werden müssen und wenn nicht, dann soll es dafür Sanktionen geben. Und das fand ich noch einen interessanten Punkt. Er ist total logisch, wenn man jetzt eben schon diese zwei Stunden vorher gehört hat. Aber Trainer dürfen nicht zu viel Macht haben, heißt es in dem Bericht etwa auch in der Rolle des Managers über Transferbestimmung. Also das ist, glaube ich, auch nochmal ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, den man auch mitnehmen kann, auch für andere Konstellationen, auch in anderen Sportarten. Es darf nie ein Mensch über das sportliche Schicksal eines Leistungssportlers oder einer Leistungssportlerin komplett entscheiden. Ist sowieso schon schwierig, dass es so wenige sind, wird sich allerdings in vielen Sportarten dann doch nicht vermeiden lassen. Aber nur einer, das ist eine Machtfülle, die ist ungesund und ich finde, das ist eigentlich auch von außen leicht einsehbar, warum das auch aus vielen anderen Gründen nicht sinnvoll ist.
Mir fällt da der sehr interessante Begriff der Gewaltenteilung, den wir aus unserem Demokratieverständnis erkennen, ein, weil wenn man das aufteilt, also die Regeln zu machen, wäre vielleicht verbandseitig, das wäre der Bundestag oder so in dem Modell, das umzusetzen, das sind halt die Clubs und deren Manager, das wäre also die Exekutive. Und dann nochmal, und da hält sich Frau Yates dann erstmal so bedeckt, die Frage, also wer ist dann die Judikative in diesem Spiel, also wer geht dann wirklich ans Eingemachte, wenn Dinge passieren. Aber ich glaube, der Bericht ist ja nicht gedacht, also jetzt ein neues Grundverständnis von, wie organisiert man Sport und Mannschaftssport aufzubauen, sondern wie vermeidet man möglichst dauerhaft solche Fälle, wie sie eben hier dokumentiert worden sind. Und da leistet der Bericht glaube ich ganz viel an Anregungen und an vernünftigen Vorschlägen, die man umsetzen kann. Und das hast du ja auch gerade schon gesagt, das wäre schon viel gewonnen, wenn das passiert.
Ja, der Bericht sagt dann auch am Schluss noch, also unbedingt sollen auch die Maßnahmen im Jugendfußball überprüft werden, weil das eben nicht Kern dieses Berichts war und trotzdem dieses Thema immer wieder aufgepoppt ist. Wir haben ja vorhin Sally Yates selbst dafür gehört und die letzte Empfehlung ist dann einfach, denkt bitte noch über noch mehrere Formen nach. Also das ist dann quasi nur die Angabe der Unvollständigkeit. Das hier alles kann nur ein Anfang sein. Und es gibt aber noch einen Teilaspekt, den haben wir jetzt gerade ganz kurz gestreift, den würde ich noch gerne kurz mit dir besprechen wollen, nämlich die Bedeutung der Jurisdiktion. Und jetzt in diesem vorliegenden Fall bekommen wir dann auch das Wort SafeSport oder die Einrichtung SafeSport vermittelt. Kannst du kurz in wenigen Sätzen erklären, was ist das eigentlich?
Ja, das ist die konzeptionell irgendwann entwickelte Idee. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wann das angefangen hat, also schon über zehn Jahre. Nach meiner Erinnerung hat das damit zu tun, wie Missbrauchsfälle im Schwimm-Sport weggewedelt worden und vertuscht worden sind. Und hat was damit zu tun, wie damals zwischen dem NOK, dem Nationalen Olympischen Komitee in Colorado Springs und dem Schwimmverband, der auch da sitzt, und welche persönlichen Verflechtungen es da gab zwischen den Leuten, die das eine leiten, das andere leiten. Und es gab eben eine ganze Reihe von in dem Fall sexuellen Missbrauchsfällen, die wurden auch zu einem erheblichen Teil, wurden die auch gerichtlich dann behandelt und diese Trainer wurden dann bestraft. Da hat man das als Konzept entwickelt. Also die Idee ist, wir wollen das wissen, was da vorgefallen ist und wir wollen dafür sorgen, dass diese Menschen, die überführt worden sind, nicht sich einfach in diesem riesigen Land von 330 Millionen Menschen dann irgendwo woanders einen Job besorgen können, der ihnen die gleiche Chance bietet, sich wieder missbrauchlich zu verhalten. Also nicht das tun, was die katholische Kirche lange getan hat, indem sie also wirklich einfach nur ihre Priester versetzt hat oder so und weiter im Amt gelassen hat. Da kommt das her und dann gab es eine Durststrecke, weil dazu braucht man natürlich Geld und Personal und da hat man eben die Prioritäten nicht so hoch gesetzt, dass es gab halt Druck. Und erst als dann der Kongress sich wirklich mit dem ganzen Komplex beschäftigt hat und auch inzwischen Gesetze dazu erlassen hat, die dann auch in Kraft getreten sind, da wurde auch geregelt, wie man das besser finanziert, wie man das aufbauen und aufstocken kann. Das heißt, die Institution dieser Behörde, die ist damit verankert. Sie ist nicht mehr einfach nur so ein wackeliges Projekt, sondern es ist völlig klar, wir brauchen das. Und in dem Bericht von Sally Yates wird das in einem bestimmten Kontext relevant, weil sie warnt davor, sich jetzt auf diese Einrichtung einfach nur zu stützen und zu verlassen und zu glauben, das gibt es ja schon und wenn wir da mit denen zusammenarbeiten, dann kriegen wir das schon alles in den Griff. Ich glaube, das ist die Erkenntnis, die man aus dem Bericht jetzt ziehen kann. Sie sagt, das ist noch nicht genug. Ihr müsst mehr tun, als nur zu sagen, ja, da gibt es ja irgendwelche Leute. Noch mal als kleiner Hinweis, wir reden hier von einer Zone, in der wahrscheinlich kaum einer dieser Fälle kriminell zu nennen wäre, also wo man wirklich nicht davon sprechen kann, dass hier ein strafrechtlich relevanter sexueller Missbrauchsakt oder mehrere Akte passiert sind, also wie zum Beispiel ein Trainer vergeht sich an einer Minderjährigen oder so. Das wäre natürlich strafrechtlich zu bewerten und da müsste man schauen, dass da auch die Polizei und die Staatsanwaltschaften eingeschaltet werden. Also das, was zum Beispiel im Turnverband eine wichtige Rolle gespielt hat, weil die meisten der Zornerinnen, um die es dagegen war, 18 und jünger. Und damit greifen ganz andere juristische Vorstellungen davon, wie man mit Menschen in dem Alter umgehen darf oder eben nicht darf. Also da ist das Strafrecht schnell dabei. Wir reden jetzt hier gerade auch bei der Profiliga von erwachsenen Frauen. Das heißt, es entsteht diese Grauzone, dass wenn die jetzt dem Druck nachgeben, und sich darauf einlassen, mit übergriffigen Menschen zusammenzubeleben, dann wird ihnen auch zugebilligt. Na ja, ihr habt ja auch die Möglichkeit, euch dem zu entziehen und ihr seid erwachsen und so weiter. Also insofern haben wir jetzt hier in diesem Bereich nicht so sehr diesen strafrechtlichen Aspekt, wie ich schon sagte, aus dem Schwimmen oder aus dem Turnen. Wir haben jetzt hier diesen Verbandsspezifischen, dieses Gefühl, wir müssen den Sport, den organisierten Sport ins 21. Jahrhundert bringen und all die Rahmenbedingungen herstellen, die dazugehören. Dazu gehört eben nicht nur, dass man hilft mir. Sind das 15 Fußballregeln, nach denen gespielt wird?
Ich glaube, ich müsste das wissen als Hörer von Kolinas Abend, aber jetzt stehe ich natürlich auf dem Schalke.
Es sind aber auf jeden Fall weniger als 20. Das reicht eben nicht. Der größte Teil der Fußballregeln besteht darin zu sagen, wie groß ist das Spielfeld und wie groß ist das Tor und wie lange wird gespielt oder so. Da wird ja gar nicht groß über Widersprüchliches verhandelt. Ihr müsst halt den Platz hier abkreiden oder so. Das reicht eben nicht, dass man so vorgeht. Und es reicht auch nicht so zu tun, wir sind hier gemeinnützig und wir sind not-for-profit und wir wollen das Wohl der Allgemeinheit fördern. Ja, schön und gut, aber ihr seid auch gleichzeitig wichtige Institutionen einer Gesellschaft, die sich verändert hat und in der man nicht so tun kann, als ließe sich das alles einfach so abhandeln. Es braucht Regeln, es braucht Vorschriften, es braucht Disziplinarregeln, es braucht eine Art von polizeilicher Aufmerksamkeit, Wachsamkeit und erst wenn das geleistet werden kann, kann man mit einigermaßen Optimismus in die Zukunft schauen.
Es sind 17 Fußballregeln, aber es braucht auch ein neues Rechtsverständnis, was wir in Teilen ja auch schon gesehen haben. Das geht jetzt dann in der andere Debatte über, das möchte ich jetzt, die Debatte müssen wir nicht führen, aber letztlich bei Nein heißt Nein-Gesetzen zum Beispiel, also jetzt eben das ist die umgangssprachliche Formulierung dafür, die Frage nach der Bedeutung von Consent bei zum Beispiel sexuellen Aktivitäten, da braucht es eben auch ein anderes Verständnis für. Und das ist ein sehr wichtiger Aspekt, den du hier mit reinbringst, dass wir uns hier in diesem Bereich eben in diesem grau Bereich bewegen, der oft straf- und zivilrechtlich nicht relevant ist, aber dennoch ja so traumatisierend für die Opfer ist, dass man das als Gesellschaft nicht akzeptieren kann, dass es so etwas gibt und es ja dann auch richtigerweise gesellschaftlich geächtet wird. Es ist jetzt zum Glück so, dass ein Paul Reilly nicht der Held Amerikas ist. Zumindest ist es nicht so bei mir angekommen. Und gleichzeitig ist da eben auch noch viel zu tun. Und ich wollte dieses Safe Spot als Institution auch deshalb hier noch mal genannt haben. Zum einen, weil es die Dimensionen auch noch mal ganz gut klarmachen kann. Also in beide Richtungen. Also der Report, der Untersuchungsbericht, der zitiert, dass ungefähr 30 Ermittlende bei Safe Sport für insgesamt 11 Millionen Athletinnen zuständig sind. Es gibt seit fünf Jahren ist Safe Spot vom Kongress als Non-Profit-Organisation, als gemeinnützige Organisation, verbrieft. In dieser Zeit gab es über 10.000 Meldungen von Missbrauch. Insgesamt 3400 Telefonate und 350 Chats, die über die Plattform geführt wurden. Die Dimensionen sind immens. Gleichzeitig ist die Unterbesetzung dieser Institution genauso wichtig. Das ist eben auch insofern relevant, weil man sich die Frage stellen kann, was ist denn unser Safe Spot, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es denn in Deutschland? Du hast es vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen. Du hast ja genau dazu auch ein Interview geführt. Ich werde es natürlich in den Showroom verlinken mit Julia Hollnagel von Athleten Deutschland. Die ist da eine der Sprecherinnen. Und ihr habt genau über solche Thematiken auch gesprochen. Wir haben es vorhin schon mal kurz angerissen. Empfehle ich den Hörern und Hörern, sich auch das nochmal zu Gemüte zu führen. Und das bringt uns vielleicht zum letzten Punkt, den ich nicht nur auf die Situation in den USA verstanden wissen möchte, heißt, was könnte jetzt passieren? Ich glaube, ein paar Dinge haben wir schon angesprochen. personelle Wechsel zum Beispiel, vielleicht ist das auch nochmal der Moment, einer Spielerin die Stimme zu geben. Becky Sauerbrunn hat sich auch dazu auf der vorhin schon zitierten Pressekonferenz im Nationalteam geäußert. Wir hören mal kurz rein, welchen Aspekt sie da nochmal hervorgekehrt hat.
Aber die Dinge, die vor ihnen passiert haben, in der Vorderkunft, als Owners sind unbezüglich.
Also, sie sagt eben auf die Frage hin, ob sie sich denn jetzt sicher oder geschützt fühle. Ja, was bedeutet das denn? Sie sagt, die Menschen, mit denen ich in meinen Teams zusammengearbeitet habe, das sind gute Menschen. Aber was da im Frontoffice, also in den Chefetagen passiert ist, das seien schreckliche Vorgänge, Dinge, die da nicht passiert seien und 100%ige Sicherheit oder ein 100%iges Schutzgefühl. Das könne es eben nicht geben und niemand sei sicher. Und das sind dann doch sehr starke Worte. Vielleicht aber auch jetzt am Ende dann auch dieser langen Sendung, Jürgen, eine recht realistische Einschätzung.
Ja, weil das, was eben in Bewegung gekommen ist, das muss ja auch sich weiter entfalten können. Und wir können jetzt nicht wirklich sagen, okay, wir wissen, wie es weitergeht. Wir werden uns vielleicht sogar in einem Jahr oder in irgendeiner Phase nochmal neu unterhalten und sagen, okay, hat dieser Bericht und dann auch die Doku, die ist wirklich sehr hilfreich, hat das irgendwas bewegt. Im Moment sind wir immer noch, und Becky's Statements sind ja ein bisschen noch aus dieser Betroffenheitsperspektive, dieser Erkenntnisentwicklung, also da ist ein Satz, den Megan Rapinoe, die bisher gar nicht richtig groß rausgekommen ist, hat jetzt erst angefangen, so ein bisschen was zu sagen. What the fuck is going on? Also so in der Phase, also dass man sagen kann, meine Güte, also das war ja alles, das ist ja alles gelaufen. Das ist ja nur nicht behandelt worden und nicht öffentlich gemacht worden. Jetzt hoffen wir, also wir werden jetzt, glaube ich, nichts dazu beitragen, aber wir begleiten das, dass die Verantwortlichen Lehren daraus ziehen, aus dem, was jetzt angelaufen ist. Und wie ich die Amerikaner kenne, ich glaube, da wird schon einiges passieren. Ich hoffe auch, dass man in Deutschland seine eigenen Schlüsse daraus zieht und vielleicht auch Wege findet. Und wenn dann die Athleten, wie in Athleten Deutschland, den Mund aufmachen und sich einsetzen an den Stellen, auch hinter den Kulissen, dann ist das auch vielversprechend. Also das tippe ich mal, wird auch eine Rolle spielen demnächst für den Sport in Deutschland.
Da kam jetzt auch, das ist ein zeitlicher Zufall, dass das so zusammengefallen ist, aber just am 27. September wurde eine Studie veröffentlicht der Aufarbeitungskommission. Das ist auch deren URL aufarbeitungskommission.de. Die haben wir auch schon mal kurz erwähnt, im Kurzpass im letzten Jahr. Und da wurde nämlich genau die Frage nicht quantifiziert, wie viel Missbrauch gibt es auch im deutschen Sport. Hier bezieht es sich vor allem auf Kinder und Jugendliche, sondern da wurden nochmal Fallbeispiele auch gezeigt, in einer leicht vergleichbaren Situation zu diesem Bericht. Ich würde ganz gerne hier einmal Bettina Ruloffs einspielen, die von der Deutschen Sporthochschule Köln mit federführend für diesen Bericht mit verantwortlich war und einfach nur mal das Augenmerk darauf lenken. Welche Bedingungen gibt es denn im Sport? Wie schätzt die das aus Sicht des Missbrauchs ein? Und jetzt reden wir über Deutschland.
Es gibt tatsächlich im Sport besondere Risiken, die es begünstigen können, dass sexualisierte Gewalt passiert. Immer vorausgesetzt, dass da jemand ist, der auch die Absicht hat, das zu tun. Wir müssen uns dabei eben auch vor Augen führen, dass sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder ja ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem ist, das eben nicht vor den Türen von Sportvereinen Halt macht. Und tatsächlich sind im Sport beispielsweise sehr viele Ehrenamtliche unterwegs, Millionen von Ehrenamtlichen, die auch tagtäglich sehr viel leisten für den Sport. Und diese Ehrenamtlichen werden aber mitunter sehr stark idealisiert. Und wenn dann hier jemand von diesen ehrenamtlichen Gewalt gegen Kinder ausübt, dann wird das oftmals übersehen, bagatellisiert und niemand möchte auch diese Ehrenamtlichen, die sich unentbehrlich machen für ihren Sportverein, anklagen. Im Leistungssport sind es zum Teil ganz andere Bedingungen, die dazu beitragen, dass hier sexuelle Gewalt ausgeübt werden kann, wenn hier beispielsweise starke Macht- oder Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse zwischen Trainern und Athletinnen und Athleten bestehen, die dann auch ausgenutzt werden können.
Also ich merke gerade, dass ich vorhin Ihr Argument schon mal gebracht habe. Das war jetzt eine Doppelung zu etwas, was ich vorhin gesagt habe. Jetzt wisst ihr auch, woher ich meine Argumentation hatte. So schlau bin ich ja dann auch nicht. Aber es ist schon frappierend, Jürgen, wenn man eben nach allem, was wir jetzt besprochen haben, sich das anguckt, sich eben jemanden anhört, die mit am besten Bescheid weiß in Deutschland zu diesem Thema, jetzt eben mit Fokus auf Kinder und Jugendliche. Und im Grunde sind die Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse und die Verhältnisse exakt so, wie wir es gerade beschrieben haben, mit Ausnahme der einen Klammer, die wir ganz vorhin gemacht haben, über den Unterschied zwischen Ehrenamt und Professionalisierung schon im Jugendfußball. Aber die Abhängigkeiten sind ja genau dieselben.
Ja, und obwohl wir ja jetzt hier hauptsächlich über Fußball geredet haben oder den Fußball von Frauen, wir können ja auch nicht die Augen schließen vor, dass das eben quer durch den Sport geht. Es ist aber sinnvoll, glaube ich, und das wäre jetzt mal so mein Versuch, das ein bisschen zusammenzubringen, was wir heute durchgesprochen haben, es ist sinnvoll, sich mal wirklich sehr viel genauer mit einer Sache zu beschäftigen, weil so viel anders geht es in anderen Sportarten ja nun auch nicht zu. Das heißt, die Mechanismen oder die Figuren oder die Konstellationen sind ähnlich. Und da kann Fußball, weil es nun auch der beliebteste Sport weltweit ist, kann natürlich auch so ein bisschen ein Leuchtturm sein für das, was man nicht unbedingt denkt, wenn man über die FIFA spricht oder über die UEFA oder so. Da hat man nicht das Gefühl, dass da das Enleitement oder das, wie nennen wir das noch mal auf Deutsch, die Phase, die philosophische, ja die Aufklärung, Gedanke da eingezogen ist. Aber wenn es dann eben von hier aus kommt und von den Frauen hier, gerne. Ich meine, auch in anderen Bereichen der amerikanischen politischen Landschaft geht der Aufruf im Moment wirklich an Frauen, sich sehr stark zu engagieren und ihre Interessen rüberzubringen. Das kann ja nur helfen.
Aber was ist denn dein Gefühl? Du hast ja vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, wie gefragt jetzt auch deine Artikel zu diesem Thema sind. Und wir reden jetzt ja auch in einem deutschen Medium darüber. Und gleichzeitig hast du ja vorhin schon gesprochen, es sind dann doch einige wenige, die sowohl daran forschen, als auch darüber berichten. Das ist kein großer Kreis an Medien. Was ist deine Einschätzung, wie wichtig wird dieses Thema sowohl medienseitig als auch dann schon sportverbandseitig genommen?
Also ich kann nicht abschätzen, also sogar ganz genau abschätzen. Also ich hatte ja schon mal gesagt, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass das in Deutschland inzwischen sehr weit gedient ist, dass man also das nicht mehr länger einfach nur so in irgendeine Ecke abdrängen kann. Weil die Falllage ist klar, es gibt ja auch Prozesse, es gibt Verurteilungen. Man kann das nicht übersehen. Die Frage, die sich immer in diesem Milieu stellt, ist, wie schnell kriegen wir eigentlich etwas umgesetzt? Es mag für uns, nachdem wir jetzt auch diesen Bericht durchgearbeitet haben, relativ sinnvoll und klar sein, dass eigentlich Aktion überall sofort notwendig wird. Das heißt, jede Sitzung, jede Vorstandssitzung in irgendeinem auf Ehrenamt basierenden Verband in Deutschland müsste eigentlich nach diesem Bericht sofort das als wichtigen Tagesordnungspunkt auch durchnehmen und sagen, was sind unsere Schlussfolgerungen aus solchen Informationen. Und ich bin aber relativ skeptisch, dass das so passiert. Ich glaube, dass fast jede eigene, jedes eigene Milieu eigene Aktionsenergie hat und oder auch nicht hat. Das heißt also, es wird schon wieder darauf hinauslaufen, dass die Athletinnen und Athleten den Mund aufmachen, was sie ja nun in Deutschland zum Glück auch jetzt tun, dass Interessenvertreter von denen mitziehen, also wie zum Beispiel die Sportwissenschaft, die sich ja darauf bezieht auf das, was im Sport passiert. Und bei der Politik in Deutschland, was den Sport angeht, da habe ich aber schon mal, glaube ich, in einem anderen Zusammenhang gesagt, da mache ich mir keine Hoffnung. Der Sportausschuss im Bundestag ist eine Lobbyisten-Spielwiese. Da kommen nicht Leute hin, die haben ein politisches Interesse daran, den Sport zu reformieren. Da kommen Leute hin, die haben Interesse daran, den Bundeshaushalt möglichst massiv zu lehren, um irgendwelche Förderungssysteme, von denen sie abhängen. Ja, oder dann auch die Finanzierung von Leistungszentren oder von Trainerstellen oder was auch immer der Sport braucht, der sich so insgesamt nicht selbst finanzieren kann. Und ja, das ist so eine sehr, sehr eingefahrene Geschichte und auch eine sehr, ich würde mal sagen, verbobene Sicht. Wenn denn also der Förderungsgedanke hauptsächlich davon abhängt, dass man am Ende in Form von Medaillen ein Nationalbewusstsein pflegen kann, dann hat man ja auch irgendwas an Sport nicht verstanden. Aber das ist nun keine, ist kein deutsches Phänomen. Das muss man ihnen jetzt nicht in die Schuhe schieben. Aber man könnte erwarten, dass das besser reflektiert wird in diesen Kreisen und dass auch Hinweise von Sportlern und von Sportlerinnen und von Medienleuten, die das mit beobachten, dass jetzt stärker aufgegriffen wird. Aber es gibt eine Phase, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die vorbei ist. Da wurden Ausschusssitzungen im Sportausschuss, da wurde die Öffentlichkeit nicht zugelassen. Jaja, das gibt es immer noch. Was ist immer noch so. Also die wollen unter sich bleiben. Daraus lässt sich keine gute Prognose ableiten.
Ja, und ich habe nämlich auch das Gefühl, dass wir hier eigentlich alle Puzzlestücke oder alle Hinweise, alle Pfeile schon vor uns liegen haben, viele Pfeile. Und die Frage ist, wie viele davon brauchen wir noch? Also wir wissen ja von Missbrauchsfällen im Reitsport. Wir wissen von Missbrauchsfällen im Schwimmen. Wir haben erst jüngst durch die Doku von H. Seppett dazu während der laufenden European Championship Games hier dazu noch neue Erkenntnisse bekommen. Es gab jetzt eben diese Studie zu sexualisierter Gewalt und Kindesmissbrauch im Kontext des Sports von Bettina Ruloffs und der Aufarbeitungskommission. Es gab eine Doku, das ist jetzt, ja doch, das geht in die Richtung, wenn ich die NDR-Doku zum Sexismus im Fußball sehe, in denen ich dann gestandene Nationalspielerinnen sehe, die einfach nur zitieren, was ihnen schon gesagt wurde und man das Gefühl hat, das kommt aus dem vorletzten Jahrhundert, nicht mal aus dem letzten Jahrhundert. Meinen Gefühl nach gibt es viele, viele Probleme, die wir hier in diesem Bericht gesehen haben. Natürlich nicht eins zu eins, aber warum sollte es die hier nicht geben? Weil die Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse und die Strukturen dieselben sind und gleichzeitig eben viele Dinge fehlen, die auch dieser Bericht aufgedeckt hat. Also ja, es gibt die Aufarbeitungskommission und es gibt die genannten Hotlines, die ich vorhin genannt habe, zu Beginn der Sendung, es gibt aber keine Strukturen innerhalb der Verbände. Wo sind die Missbrauchsbeauftragten? Das ist jetzt ein schlechtes Wort dafür, wir müssten ein besseres Wort dafür finden. Aber wo sind die? In jedem, eigentlich bis auf kleinster Ebene, wo sind die Fortbildungen? Wie sehr wird das wirklich auch beim Trainer-Lizenzierungen mitgedacht? Jetzt nicht nur im Fußball, sondern auch in anderen Sportarten. Ich habe das Gefühl, vielleicht bin ich da auch Kultur-Pessimist, ich weiß es nicht, wobei es damit mit Kultur nichts zu tun hat, einfach nur Pessimist. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, wir stehen hier vor einem ganz großen Problem, denn dass wir immer wieder so kurz aufflackern sehen, eben mit Veröffentlichungen, eben ganz viel im Deutschlandfunk oder durch Dokus, die dann produziert werden. Aber offenbar hatten wir noch nicht den großen umstürzenden Moment, den jetzt hoffentlich, muss man ja sagen, die USA haben jetzt im Frauenfußball an unserem Beispiel gerade besprochen, der dann wirklich etwas mal verändert.
Also es gibt so Teile der Geschichte, die eben nicht überall möglich sind. Also dass Frauen wie Megan Rapinoe und Alex Morgan und andere berühmt sind und dass sie den Mund aufgemacht haben, auch schon vorher in anderen Dingen, ist Teil der Vorgeschichte. Das heißt, das Vorleben von selbstbewusster politisch zu verstehender Haltung in der Öffentlichkeit und die Öffentlichkeit, die das dann akzeptiert, dass Frauen den Mund aufmachen, das ist ein wichtiger Schritt, der schon stattgefunden hat. Und das kann man in Deutschland noch nicht so richtig erkennen, zumindest nicht von hier aus. Ich bin ein bisschen weit weg, dass solche Profilierungsanstrengungen auch wirklich Erfolg haben. Also da haben wir mehr so diese Pechstein-Nummer. Also jemand, der aus persönlichen Gründen irgendwie alle Prozesse der Welt führt oder so. Aber niemand, also ich sehe das jetzt zumindest nicht, korrigiere mich, niemand, der wirklich so diese Schuhe auch anziehen würde. Und manchmal glaube ich, in unserem mediengeprägten Verständnis von Dingen ist das nicht unwichtig. Die kann man nicht züchten, diese Persönlichkeiten, die muss man hoffen, dass sie sich entwickeln. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein Faktor in all dem, dass man also sagt, ja es geht nicht nur darum, dass Frauen jetzt zum Beispiel auf die Straße gehen, dass sie den Mund aufmachen, dass sie Politiker, Briefe oder E-Mails schreiben und dass sie Petitionen auf die Beine stellen. Es geht auch um diese Entwicklung, dass Frauen spezifisch für bestimmte Problemkonstellationen auch profiliert sind und als, was sage ich, bewusst Experten für dieses Thema figurieren können. Und das braucht es auch, weil solche Frauen wie Alice Schwarzer gehören eigentlich vom Markt genommen.
Ja, ich verstehe deinen Punkt, mir gefällt es aber ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht so ganz hier einen Schwarzen Peter jetzt den Frauen zuzuschieben, den potenziellen Opfern. Also wie gesagt, ich verstehe deinen Punkt und gleichzeitig stelle ich mir aber die Frage, wir müssen doch der Steigbügelhalter sein für Frauen, denn die, also wer Opfer von Misshandlungen wurde, wer missbraucht wurde, der ist ja in der höchst vulnerablen Situation, die man sich vorstellen kann und sich da zu öffnen, ist extrem schwierig und man kann das nicht erwarten, man kann das nicht erhoffen. Also ich kann hier glaube ich auch gleich noch mal ein Zitat von Bettina Ruloffs einspielen, die das eben im Bezug auf ihre aktuelle Studie, also es ist nicht ihre Studie, ich personalisiere das jetzt immer so auf sie, aber auf die Studie sagt, ich glaube ich spiele das mal ein und dann wird vielleicht auch mein Punkt noch mal klar.
Die Berichte der Betroffenen sind erschütternd. Es geht hier um schwere sexuelle Gewalt, die Kindern im Sport angetan wurde, häufig eben in Form von Vergewaltigungen, sexuellen Übergriffen, die mehrfach stattgefunden haben, auch zum Teil über lange Zeiträume und die von Erwachsenen in Positionen des Sports, meistens im Sportverein zum Beispiel als Trainer ausgeübt wurde. Und diese Gewalterfahrungen belasten die Betroffenen ein Leben lang, sie wiegen sehr schwer.
Das ist das, was ich jetzt gerade so ein bisschen andeuten wollte. Also wir können doch auch nicht von den Traumatisierten erwarten. Ich spitze jetzt etwas zu, dass sie uns die Bürde nehmen, von ihrem Trauma zu lesen, indem wir nämlich die Situation verbessern. Denn letztlich ist es ja für alle belastend, die sich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzen. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber natürlich die allergrößte Belastung für diejenigen, die es mal selbst am eigenen Leib erfahren mussten.
Also da fühle ich mich jetzt missverstanden, aber ich weiß nicht genau, wie das passiert ist. Mir geht es nicht darum, zu sagen, in dem Fall die Betroffenen müssen was machen, sondern mir geht es mehr um die Erklärung für den medialen Kontext. Also in dem Fall, wo man Frauen hat wie Megan Rapinoe, die sich über andere Sachen bereits profiliert haben, finden die auch mehr Gehör oder leichter Gehör, weil man da schon weiß, das sind, deshalb nannte ich das ja auch mal so, Expertinnen. Das sind Expertinnen für Sport, also Sport der Frauen unter diesen Bedingungen. Das haben wir also gemerkt, als es um den Kampf der Frauen für bessere Bezahlung und Gleichbehandlung an der Stelle ging. Das merken wir auch in anderen Sportarten hier, wenn es darum geht, zu sagen, Leute, das ist ein Anliegen. Weil sonst landet das auf den Tischen von anderen Leuten. Und die sind eben, das ist die Erfahrung jetzt ja über so viele Jahrzehnte, die sind eben entweder nicht willens oder nicht in der Lage oder nicht interessiert, ihren Job zu machen. Aber ich sage jetzt nicht, der Job ist jetzt hauptsächlich der der Betroffenen, sondern die Hilfe, die das hat, wenn man schon eine bestimmte Stellung hat im gesellschaftlichen Rahmen, das ist natürlich groß. Das ist genauso, wenn Serena oder Venus Williams über Rassismus reden oder so. Ich meine, da hört man hin. Das meine ich damit.
Ja, entschuldige, da habe ich dich tatsächlich völlig falsch verstanden. Ich schiebe es jetzt einfach mal auf die deutsche Uhrzeit, die wir gerade haben. Im Grunde genau das, was wir im letzten Jahr hatten. Im Kurzpass haben wir ganz viel über einen Tweet von Megan Rapino gesprochen, in dem sie eben gesagt hat, burn it all down, let their heads roll, ungefähr so war, war ihr Tweet. Und sie war eben nicht die Betroffene, aber sie hat sich damit mit den Betroffenen solidarisiert und ihnen eine Plattform verschafft und letztlich muss man eben auch sagen, wegen ihrer Bekanntheit einen der entscheidenden Anstöße dafür geliefert, dass eben diese Druckwelle, wie du es vorhin genannt hast, losgetreten wurde. Das war das, was du meintest.
Ja, und das, was ich aus der Ferne so nicht mitkriege, aber vielleicht ist da wirklich, da liege ich da falsch, ich sehe nicht so diese profilierten Athletinnen in Deutschland, die das auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise, das Banner, mittragen helfen, sondern ich sehe halt sehr nachdenkliche, sehr reflektierende Sportlerinnen, die sich auch nicht den Mund verbieten lassen oder so, aber sie dringen ja auch nicht unbedingt durch, bis hin zu klaren Handlungsmaximen, die da entwickelt werden. Und das ist ja hier auch nicht passiert. Also da braucht es eben auch mehr als nur eine Megan Rapinoe, die sagte, burn it all down. Also da braucht es dann eben auch eine Sally Yates, die das dann fundiert, was vorher vielleicht eher amorph in der Öffentlichkeit behandelt wird.
Gott sei Dank gibt es diese Frauen. Ja, ich glaube, da hast du eine Schleife um dieses lange Gespräch gebunden, Jürgen. Ich bin sehr, sehr froh und sehr dankbar, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, obwohl du ja beileibe jetzt noch genügend zu tun hast, auch nach dieser Aufnahme. Ich verneige mich im schlechten Gewissen vor dir und bedanke mich aber ganz herzlich, dass du hier mitgemacht hast, mal wieder im Rasenfunk. Danke dir, Jürgen.
Ja, tut mir leid, dass wir immer die ganz langen Riemen dir durchnehmen. An wem von uns beiden liegt das? Erstens liegt es auch an uns beiden, dass uns das wirklich interessiert und uns auch bewegt. Und dass diese Themen verdient haben, behandelt zu werden, aber eben nicht mit so ein paar Stichworten einfach abgehandelt werden können, also nicht in dieser Clickbait- oder Soundbite-Dimension. Zum Beispiel diese ESPN-Doku ist 90 Minuten, also vielleicht 85 oder so, aber die ist richtig lang. Und lässt auch Platz, also den gestalterischen, ästhetischen Platz, also da kommt jetzt nicht eine Information nach der anderen. Also wir reden ja jetzt hier relativ kompress, also wir könnten ja noch Musik reinlegen und das Ganze ein bisschen auflockern. Haben wir nicht gemacht, also wir haben den Leuten was zugemutet. Aber ich habe ja die Erfahrung mit dir schon gesammelt, weil du das alles sehr gut strukturierst und vorbereitest, dass dann am Ende kommen meistens sehr positive Rückmeldungen darüber, dass Menschen interessiert sind, das auch in ihrer komplett irgendwie anzuhören. Verblüffend, aber positiv und ich bin den Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörern sehr verbunden, dass sie das hoffentlich auch diesmal wieder auf sich nehmen.
Ja, ich hoffe es auch, aber ich gehe eigentlich fast davon aus, und das ist tatsächlich immer wieder aufs Neue verblüffend und immer aufs Neue schön. Ich kann nur empfehlen, folgt Jürgen gerne auf Twitter at American Arena und ich kann auch wirklich nochmal dein Buch empfehlen, Jürgen. Ich habe es so gerne gelesen, ich habe es dir ja auch damals geschrieben. Es hat für mich nochmal so ganz viele Dinge, die ich auch gerne machen würde, in meinem bescheidenen, sportjournalistischen Dasein irgendwie nochmal so herausgeklärt, weil man doch auch manchmal verzweifelt an seinem eigenen Tun, und es ist ja nur Fußball, und da redet er irgendwie über irgendwelche Sexer, die verschieben, es interessiert auch keinen. Und du hast aber diesen größeren Rahmen und was eben Sportjournalismus auch sein kann, aufgemacht, und da habe ich ganz viele Dinge entdeckt, in denen ich mir immer wieder gesagt habe, das möchte ich auch tun, zwar schaffe ich das nicht auf einer täglichen Basis, das Brot-und-Butter-Geschäft bleibt quasi, mir neun Männer-Bundesliga-Spiele und seit kurzem sechs Frauen-Bundesliga-Spiele anzugucken und zu analysieren, aber immer mal wieder diese anderen Dinge gerne auch mit dir, also der Stoff, aus dem die Helden sind, ich kann es wirklich empfehlen. Danke dir, Jürgen. Und dann empfehle ich an dieser Stelle einfach auch nochmal ganz schamlos unsere beiden Sendungen zum FIFA-Prozess, zum einen ein Tribünengespräch der FIFA-Prozess und dann gab es noch einen Kurzpass zu den Urteilen im FIFA-Prozess, also genau das Umgedrehte zum jetzigen und ich möchte nochmal dann jetzt am Schluss nochmal die Hotline-Nummern durchsagen. Betroffene, die Hilfe finden wollen bei sexuellem Missbrauch oder in Bezug auf sexuellen Missbrauch können sich melden, kostenfrei und anonym unter 0800 22 555 30 und wer sich auf sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch betroffen fühlt oder das aufarbeiten möchte, kann unter 0800 40 300 40 sich melden. All das wird natürlich auch nochmal in den Show-Notes verlinkt. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir sind sehr gespannt auf euer Feedback ohne Phishing vor Kompliments. Das möchte ich ausdrücklich betonen. Es ist eine Herausforderung gewesen, dieses Tribünengespräch. Ich bin froh, dass ich sie nicht alleine meistern musste. Und ich bin sehr gespannt auf eure Rückmeldung und dann auf die weiteren Entwicklungen in diesem ganzen großen Themenkomplex. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bleibt gesund unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, könnt ihr uns Feedback geben. Wir freuen uns außerdem, wenn ihr uns unterstützt, auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und ansonsten hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder hier in Rasenfunk, im Rasenfunk in einem Format eurer Wahl. Macht es gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.